This is Jocko podcast number one 29 with Echo Charles and me,
Jocko Willink.
Good Evening Echo.
Good evening
cry.
I had risen for the reserve and it must come as soon as possible.
We ran what we could run.
Our lieutenant colonel fell killed almost at the first.
Beyond this,
we lost our major and indeed all of the officers,
but three,
three only.
We had crossed two successive ditches which lay in an orchard to the left of the
first houses in and we were beginning to form in front of the village,
but there was no standing of it besides the general cannon fire such as hardly
can be imagined.
There was also a reign of case shot upon this battalion of which I,
as there was no colonel left,
had to take command,
a third battalion of the Royal Prussian foot guards,
which had already made several of our regiments pass.
That same kind of muster gave at a distance of 80 paces.
The liveliest fire upon us.
It stood as if on the parade ground that third battalion
and waited for us without stirring
the Austrian regimen at our right hand.
Could not get itself formed properly because of the houses.
It was standing 30 deep and sometimes it's shots hit us in the back
on my left.
The Austrian regiment ran its way and I was glad of that in comparison.
By no method or effort could I get the drag dunes who stood 50 yards to the rear
of me to cut Ian a little and help me out.
My soldiers who were still tired from running had no cannon support.
We're scattered fewer in number and we're mainly fighting out of solidness.
It was more out of honor then the notion of doing good in the affair that
prevented us from running off.
Finally,
two officers of the granted deers brought me what they still had some Hungarians
to.
We're luckily got together,
but it lasts with all help and the remnants of my own brave battalion
I drew back.
Okay,
and that right is a report
from Charles Joseph Lamar.
Raul,
okay.
The prints,
prints d'alene,
I believe is how you say it.
Who was the captain in the Austrian army fighting against the Prussians during
the seven years war.
And that particular battle was the battle of Luth,
which took place on December 5th,
where the Austrians suffered about 22,000 casualties,
about one third of their forces
that was at the hands of the Prussian army,
who interestingly had about half the number of troops as the Austrians.
Okay.
And the Prussian army was led by a guy by the name of King Frederick,
the second who became known as Frederick.
The great,
and you know,
this type of fighting was,
it was brutal and it's,
it's sort of is the classic of vision of the old European infantry tactics.
Like what you picture troops lined up by rank,
marching forward to close with the enemy in what often became just a test of
will and courage
and who's will and whose courage was stronger,
who would drive forward and who was going to back down,
who going to run away.
But on top of that will encourage you also,
there was still maneuvers happening out there and the movements were
centralized,
but the,
but the maneuvers were still happening,
happening,
and the battlefields still required there to be leadership,
to maneuver these elements around,
to assess what was happening and then to drive the troops to get the job done.
Leadership was absolutely required in one of the most respected leaders of this
era was the leader at that battle of the Prussians.
Frederick the great.
Now Frederick the great,
interesting character,
born in 1712 his father,
Frederick William,
and he,
he seemed like one of those kind of tyrannical fathers that really pushed his
son with extreme discipline and all that.
And guess what?
Young Frederick didn't like?
It
didn't like it wasn't,
wasn't into that.
You know what?
He was into music literature.
That's what he was into.
And he actually plotted an escape to England and he had a couple of his buddies
helped him out,
had a little plan,
put the plan together.
I'm gonna get out,
get away from my tyrannical dad who's trying to turn me into this warmongering
guy.
And the plot got foiled and the king actually captured you,
captured one of the two friends that was helping young Frederick and incentives
them to death.
And Young Frederick had to watch his friend who had tried to help him get
beheaded.
Yeah.
And despite that he eventually got on board with becoming a military leader and
become an king.
And he gained a reputation for being extremely aggressive on the battlefield.
And there's a good quote,
I think Napoleon had a good quote about him,
which was something along the lines of if Frederick the great was still here,
we wouldn't be here.
So he,
he got a lot of respect than he led very successful campaigns all over Europe.
He was,
he was known for having an extremely hard work ethic,
strong work ethic.
Interestingly,
he woke up
at either four or five o'clock in the morning every morning.
So he,
he was one of those guys.
And another interesting thing at a time when,
when the royals all over Europe and the world,
when they kind of flaunted their riches,
he wasn't like that.
He was kind of like a low profile guy.
He allowed free speech,
he allowed people to even insult him,
which was,
you know,
I mean obviously he's old man,
didn't have any problem just tossing out the death sentence.
But there was a story about him where there was like a poster hung up that
someone had done a drawing and it made him kind of look like a buffoon.
And he was going through this village where this thing was hung up and he kind
of went to see what all this commotion,
all these people around.
Do you want to see what all the commotion was,
uh,
was about.
And he saw this sign hand hanging up on a post and his comment was,
hey,
lower that sign down a little bit.
So people don't hurt their next while they're looking at it.
He's just one of those guys.
And you know,
so we kind of had his ego in check,
which is,
which is definitely good.
And is his tactics.
Like I said,
I mean there's still,
even when you had these rigid sort of ranks in battles,
you still had to maneuver the out the elements around the battlefield and his
tactics were based in the mobility and being able to move quickly,
being able to move more quickly than the enemy.
And he focused on drill and more drilling.
And this is another interesting thing
in his opinion,
he cause drill.
I don't know if you know this,
but when we say drill in the military,
we're talking about you ever seen like a drill team with the rifles and they
march and everything's perfect.
A few good men,
the Edne remember that movie at the beginning as a criminal?
That's what it is.
I haven't,
I can't remember that.
I've definitely seen the movie,
but I can't remember that particular part.
But yeah,
that's what drill is.
So when people talk about drill,
that's what they're talking about.
And he was saying he,
you know,
he was of the opinion that people often miss mistook drill for the art of war.
He's no,
they're two different things and they're important.
And there's a reason why you do drill and it teaches you certain things.
It teaches you a lot about discipline.
It teaches you about responding to orders quickly,
teaches you how to work together as teams.
So there's,
there's definitely a reason for drill,
but that is not the art of war at all.
So at age 35 he was,
he had been sick and he was recovering from an illness,
but he was,
I guess I'm still a little bit down.
So he was doing what he could in in this case,
in this case,
it meant that he wrote down,
so some of his principles and the first version of it,
what's called the instruction of Frederick,
the great to his generals.
And that piece was it kind of revised and the title was eventually changed to
general principles of war.
Yeah.
And we're going to look at that book today and see what we can learn from
Frederick the great.
And I was actually,
I'm always surprised at how much I have to learn and how much I can learn from
people that fought several hundred years ago and led several hundred years ago.
It's amazing.
It's amazing what you can learn from these folks.
All right,
so here we go.
Going to the book.
This section is called the capabilities of Prussian troops and their particular
merit.
The greatest force of the Prussian army resides in their wonderful regularity,
which long costume has made a habit,
inexact obedience,
and in the bravery of the troops.
The discipline of these troops now we evolved into habit,
has such effect that in the greatest confusion of an action and the most evident
perils there disorder is still more orderly than the good order of their
enemies.
So,
so there you go.
This is,
this is discipline equals freedom in whatever 17 something.
Okay.
If you think about what he's saying,
his troops were so disciplined that even when there's total chaos going on in
there,
okay.
In their worst state,
they still are more squared away than the enemies because they're discipline is
so strong.
Hmm.
Back to the book.
Consequently small confusions are redressed in a moment and all evolutions are
made promptly.
It doesn't matter what you do to confusion,
no problem.
We got discipline.
A general of other troops could be surprised and circumstances in which he would
not be if commanding Prussians since he will find resources in the speed with
which they form and maneuver in the presence of the enemy.
And this is something that I say all the time was that like in a seal platoon,
in my seal platoons,
in my seal task unit,
in an Army or marine corps,
Infantry Platoon,
the discipline that they,
it gives them more freedom,
freedom on the battlefield because they can react to things quicker.
That's exactly what we're talking about.
Exactly.
Exact same thing.
Frederick the great realized back to the book,
Prussians discipline renders these troops capable of executing the most
difficult maneuvers such as traversing award in battle without losing their
files or distances.
Advancing and close order at double time forming with promptness,
reversing their direction suddenly to fall on the flank of the enemy,
gaining an advantage by a forced march and finally in surpassing the enemy in
constancy.
And fortitude.
Discipline equals freedom.
I'm glad he didn't use that title.
He could have,
he could have.
Now he's got something in here.
And,
and when I,
when I initially read this part,
um,
I was like,
oh,
well that's a little bit off of my thoughts,
but he comes back to it later and we'll get to that part.
Remind me actually when he,
what do you get to this part?
Talking about decentralized command because he talks about something that's a
little bit opposite of what I usually say.
So here we go back to the book,
obedience to the officers.
And subordination is so exact that no one ever questions in order.
Hours are observed.
Exactly.
And however little a general knows how to make himself obeyed,
he is always sure to be no one ever reasons about the possibility of an
enterprise.
And finally it's accomplishment is never disparative.
So what he's saying there is,
you know,
like everyone just listens to me.
That's what the g everyone just listens and no one questions the orders and
we're going to get to later where he actually,
there's two things.
Number one,
he really takes care of his people.
So they listened to him because he takes care of them.
It's not because he barks orders of them,
it's not.
It's that he really cares about them and he takes care of them.
And the other thing he talks,
and we'll talk later about this,
is how getting input from people is important.
So even though he lays that out there,
I think that's almost like a little macho.
He thought he's throwing some macho,
hey,
look at me.
Everyone just listens to me.
That's the way it is.
I don't know if you noticed this when we had a colonel Phife on the podcast,
and I was talking about this with Dave Burke the other day
when we first were,
we're talking with Colonel Fife,
you know,
he was saying,
yeah,
well,
you know,
everyone just did what I told them to do and I was kind of like,
wow,
you know that,
that I always say that that doesn't really work.
You know what's,
I'm thinking this to myself,
you know,
he says,
yeah,
people just tell him what to do and they do it.
That's what made my group,
my unit so good.
And I was like,
wow.
And then he went into it and when he went into it,
all of the answers were there.
He was like,
no,
I cared about my guys.
And then you went into,
I don't know if you remember this,
you went into this part about when he said,
look,
if you're in a tank and you tell someone to get out of the tank when the tanks
are hitting,
bullets are hitting the same.
Yeah.
And go fix the track.
Do you think they're going to do that just because you told them to?
No,
they're not.
Not if you don't take care of them.
Not if they don't say so.
Even though he initially said kind of like what Frederick the greatest saying,
hey,
people are just going to listen to me both saying the same kind of thing.
But both of them have a lot more depth behind that reaction from their troops.
So when,
when ever somebody hears something like that,
it's like,
no,
it's not true.
It doesn't work.
As a matter of fact,
there's a chapter in the new book coming out that life and I wrote and waves
talking about this one CEO that we're working with that's kind of like quoting
patent,
like discipline is the ultimate and same thing.
Laughs talking to the guy like,
hey,
that's not the way the military works.
And he believed that when he would hear this kind of thing,
this is like a macho thing to say,
right?
Is that the right word?
I don't know if that's the right word.
It's a,
it's a bold statement.
Hey,
my troops just listen to me.
Right.
It's not true.
There's so much more depth and that makes that actually happened.
Yeah.
All right.
Going back to the book,
the Prussians are superior to their enemies in constancy since the officers who
have no other profession nor other fortune to hope from except their arms and
made themselves with ambition and a gallantry beyond all test because the
soldier has a confidence in himself and because he makes it a point of honor to
never give way.
So I just,
we were working with a company,
uh,
doing a,
doing an FTX training,
you know,
so we're out in the field and I was talking to them about come from move and I
said,
if you're walking while you're covering your field of fire from a level of one
to 10 how well can you do it?
And you know,
people like,
I don't know,
five,
six.
Cause when you're walking you can't really,
you know,
you've got to look where you're walking there.
Look what everyone else is doing.
You,
you can't just look at your field of fire.
You can't just look at your field of fire,
which is where you're looking for threats.
I said,
when you do cover move and you stop and you get behind some cover and then you
just,
your whole job is just to look how good you do one to 10 and everyone's like 10
and I said,
yeah.
And,
and that's kind of the same thing here where you get this guy when you have
people that their whole life is just dedicated to one thing,
well then they're going to do it good.
He's a Prussian officers who had nothing else going for them other than being in
the military,
they're going to do a good job of it.
That's why sometimes people ask me,
should I start another job while I'm on active duty?
And quite frankly,
my answer is no.
It's if you do,
it's gotta be so on the side that it doesn't interfere at all with your job as
being a,
being in the military,
it's just too hard to balance two things.
Can you give a little advice?
Can you maybe set something up on the side?
Yeah,
but dedicate focus on focus on what you're doing.
100% there's nothing else that I don't know.
I just don't,
I don't see that as working out very well.
I say just focus on what you're doing.
That's my opinion.
Some people pull it off.
I've never known anyone that pulled it off.
Well,
maybe I could think of some.
Most people that had some kind of side gig going on the the,
the military was their side Gig too.
You know what I mean?
They weren't just in the game.
Yeah.
Like,
no,
dude,
do your job,
do it.
Well,
yeah,
that doesn't go with,
if you're working for some corporation,
then you can pull it off.
Right.
You can have,
you can do something on the side.
Depends on the job,
but I don't know,
it just seems like if you're the boss of of let's say you had a team,
right.
And they were like,
you know,
they're,
productivity and all,
you know,
all this stuff,
and then you find out one team member is basically splitting his time.
You know,
I don't know,
doing something else.
It's kind of like,
whoa,
Whoa,
whoa.
We're all over here Tryna,
if it's interfering,
but most jobs aren't 24 hours to answer not or leaving.
True.
Yeah.
You know what?
I think you can pull it off and you can pull off way easier in any other job
than in the military.
Yeah.
You can have something going on the side.
Because the military is the job where it's like 24 hours a day.
Yeah.
Are you,
are you saying in a combat scenario we're talking about just in general,
just in general.
And I shouldn't say that.
You know,
there's a lot of jobs where I work with companies.
There's people that are,
they're doing it 24 hours a day.
They're in the game.
Yeah.
So if you're in one of those kind of jobs,
don't get a side job and aren't there like or sub self up properly that you can
do it.
It's hard to pull off,
man.
It's hard to pull off.
But aren't there jobs in the military that are,
that are pretty mellow?
There are where you can come in.
There are,
I guess if you're doing that,
maybe you can do it.
Yeah.
You're thinking of you like your,
yeah,
but I'm also thinking about like guys and guys in the seal teams.
That's what the guys in the seal teams that had some kind of side hustle going
on.
We're genuinely,
they weren't fully in the game,
you know?
That's just the way it is.
And maybe there's some guys that I didn't even know about that did it,
but most people like,
hey,
if you're out buying houses and flipping houses,
you know you can kind of do that when you're in the military because you just
doing some hard work on the weekends and that's cool.
Good to get a little rental property going.
Hey,
right on.
Yeah,
I did that.
It wasn't,
it wasn't.
It literally interfered zero with my primary job,
which was getting out
all right.
Back to the book.
Many have been seen to fight even when wounded,
since the organization in general,
proud of its past brave engagements considers that any soldier who has shown the
least cowardice,
inaction upfront,
front tip.
I like that.
So you have that attitude.
You have that that culture inside your organization.
It's a real thing.
We don't back down.
We keep fighting hard.
That's where we do.
All right.
Now he talks a little bit about projects of campaign.
One should no one's enemies,
their alliances,
their resources and the nature of their country.
In order to plan a campaign,
one should know what to expect of one's friends.
What resources one has oneself and see the future effects to determine what one
has to fear or hope from political maneuvers.
We've heard this over and over again.
Understand your enemy.
Back to the book.
Extravagant camp projects of campaign are worthless.
I call extravagant.
Those which require you to make penetrations or those which reduce you to a two
rigid defense penetrations are worthless because in pushing too far into the
enemy's country,
you weaken yourself.
Your communications become very difficult to maintain on account of their
length.
And in order to make assured conquests,
it is necessary always to pref.
Proceed within the rules.
And here's the rules to advance.
Establish yourself cyl solidly to advance again to establish yourself the same
and always to prepare to have within your reach of your army,
your resources and your requirements.
So there he's saying,
make sure you're ready and if you got to extend yourself,
don't extend yourself too far.
That's,
that's what he's saying.
that's very good advice.
Now he also says this note,
so that's going on the offense.
Now there's a dichotomy here which we talk about Dichotomy Hill hot.
There's a dichotomy here cause he's saying,
hey look,
you gotta be careful going on super,
super far distant offense and extending yourself too far.
But then he says this back to the book,
projects of absolute defensive are not practicable because while wishing to
close yourself in strong camps,
the enemy will envelop you,
deprive you of your sustenance from the rear and oblige you to lose ground while
disheartening your troops.
So while you're digging in,
guess what?
The enemy's going to maneuver on you and cut and cut you off.
Now back to the book,
I prefer to this conduct of the offensive with the hazard of losing the battle,
since this will not be more fatal than your retreat and you're timid,
defensive.
So he's saying there,
he'd rather be aggressive,
be lean towards being me at more aggressive than leading towards being more
defensive.
And He,
and he says,
why in the one you lose ground by withdrawing and soldiers by desertion and you
have no hope.
So if you go on the defense,
that's what happens.
You lose ground,
you lose soldiers and you have no hope.
Jadah now on the offense,
he says in the other,
you do not risk more,
and if you are fortunate,
you can hope for the most brilliant success.
What does he say in their attack?
That's what he's saying.
I agree with that.
Again,
there's a dichotomy there because he's saying attack,
but the,
the previous paragraph,
he's saying,
don't overextend yourself.
This is why we're writing a book called the dichotomy of leadership,
because you have to find that balance.
All right,
back to the book.
I am now coming to what I,
the defensive,
which turns into the offensive,
the greatest secret of war and the masterpiece of a skillful general is to
starve his enemy.
Hunger exhausts men more surely than courage,
and you will succeed with less risk than by fighting.
But since it is very rare that a war is ended by the capture of a depot and
matters are only decided by great battles,
it is necessary to employ all these means to attain this object.
Okay?
Starving your enemy.
You don't notice the interestingly,
you know what I was thinking about would that popped into my mind is when
you're,
when you're dealing with relationships,
one of the best ways to like win in a relationship scenario is you starve the
other person of attention.
What do you mean?
We,
it's so,
uh,
to,
yeah,
to win.
So like when you,
what's the worst thing you can do to your kid when your kid is doing something
bad?
Give it attention.
Yeah.
The worst thing you can do is,
yeah,
let's give it attention.
The best thing you can do is starve it of attention.
Yeah.
I just thought that was kind of interesting.
And another thing is like in Jujitsu,
you start with a person of energy,
right?
You make them use their energy and once they're out of energy,
they're done.
Gotcha.
Yeah.
So I guess it depends on what you mean by when the relationship,
I guess I didn't really phrase that correctly,
but I was thinking of what we generally do.
Let me clarify that.
I think I just figured it out a little bit.
What we generally do is if we've got a problem in a relationship,
but what do we do?
We go to fight it and go to war.
The better thing.
Maybe just to starve,
starve it a little bit.
How do you start it?
Start it from attention,
right?
Like we talked about it,
I think it was last week.
There's someone asked like,
how do you get vengeance?
And I was like,
Hey,
the best thing,
the best interventions to give,
starve them of attention.
Yup.
Don't even give it to them.
Yeah,
you're going to,
that's the win.
Yeah.
So I guess it's not good to put that in perspective with your kids.
Really.
Not a good dig any battle scenario,
interrelationship.
Sure.
They get,
yeah.
I think as shrinking.
And you could definitely go too far with that.
Oh yeah.
Yeah.
No,
I'm not saying starve.
I guess if you're,
if you're talking about,
I guess more than anything else,
I'm not even saying it's good or bad.
I'm saying it's something to be aware of that you can use attention as a tool to
help you in,
in your engagements,
in relationships,
in business,
in life,
in family,
whatever.
You can use that attention as a tool.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
I think that's more appropriate.
Yeah.
Cause then pay attention to your kids.
Cause when you say relationship you automatically assume wife,
kids,
girlfriend,
boyfriend kind of thing.
I don't automatically that.
Yeah,
it was like,
yeah.
Okay.
He any,
any battle situation where like,
yeah.
Any combatives combatives near.
Yeah.
I'm just saying it's another tool.
I'm glad you,
it's a good one.
Yeah.
By the way,
it's a good one.
It is a good one.
Right here.
He talks about it and by the way,
obviously I'm cutting out big chunks.
And what's interesting is he talks about heat for each one of these little
principles that he talks about.
He actually goes through specific historical battles that happened and how they
unfolded.
But if you want to read those,
you should get the book.
But yeah.
Okay.
I wanted to get through all the principles.
So here we go.
This is kind of skipping the,
the,
uh,
the battles and his,
his battles.
They're not,
they're not like these first person kind of accounts that are really moving.
They're more just,
um,
historical perspective.
Hey,
here's,
and he wasn't even at owl owl,
all of them,
you know,
some of you saying this is what happened in this place and this is what happened
in this other place.
Hmm.
Alright.
He's talking here about rest camps.
The duty of the general in these sort of camps is to restore his army and
personally to oversee order and discipline.
The cavalry and infantry should be visited often and examined to determine if
the first is well nourished and if these two cores are complete.
So take care of your people.
Likewise,
the troop should be exercised frequently.
Cavalry as well as infantry.
And the general should be,
uh,
should often be present to praise the ones to criticize the others and to see
with his own eyes that the orders which are found in my institution,
military are observed.
Exactly.
Okay.
The camp guards should be visited to see if they are vigilant,
if the officer's attentive or if he is negligent to be extremely strict so that
the amount did centuries.
We'll model out anyone to enter the camp without examining and announcing him
and to prevent desertion by all means that I have indicated previously.
He talks about one of the problems they had is people deserting and he goes into
how do you stop people from deserting?
It's that's what he's referring to there.
Things that keeping everyone busy,
making sure that they're well fed.
He talks about those kinds of things,
so that's what he's referring.
Two
got exercise and frequently got to keep him busy
and you have to inspect.
You have to get eyes on,
he says with your own eyes,
so when you're the leader you just can't throw that order out there and expect
it's all going to happen the way you expected it to.
Not going to happen.
You got to go spend it with your own eyes.
Back to the book,
Nala.
Oh,
before I go back to the book,
he's going to talk about
how important it is to understand the battlefield and the terrain.
Here we go.
Knowledge of the country is to a general what a rifle is to an infantry man and
what the rules of arithmetic are to a geo Mac.
Trition.
Okay.
If he does not know the country,
he will do nothing but make gross mistakes without this,
without this knowledge,
his projects be them otherwise admirable become ridiculous and often
impracticable.
Therefore study the country where your going to act
when his desire to apply oneself to this essential part of war.
The most detailed and exact maps of the country that can be found are taken an
examined and reexamined frequently if it is not in time of war.
The places are visited,
camps are chosen,
roads are examined.
The mayors of the villages,
the butchers and the farmers are talked to.
One becomes familiar with the foot pass and the depth of the wood there.
Nature and the depth of the rivers there.
Practicable marshes and those which are not and one observes in this study to
distinguish carefully between the conditions of the marshes and the streams in
the different seasons of the year.
It cannot be said that a stream is impracticable in the month of August because
it had been in the month of April.
The road is chosen to be taken on such and such a march.
The number of columns in which the march can be made and all the strong camping
places found on the route are examined to see if they can be used.
Gathered your Intel,
gathering,
your Intel.
This is critical on the battlefield and my first deployment to Iraq,
I didn't do this as much as if I as I should have because we'd be going to a
place for the first time and we'd go there,
we'd get a quick kind of information,
intelligence would come in and we'd go,
okay,
we're going to,
we find out what this guy is and we do a quick map study.
You know,
we do a map study,
but it wasn't as thorough as as when we were in Ramadi for six straight months.
And you actually just knew where you were.
Uh,
and somebody just hit me up on Twitter talking about this,
but there was a guy from the first of five Oh six,
a company commander and he was awesome.
And he videoed,
he had video cameras in his humvees.
And so when he's out driving around Ramadi,
he would record it and then when he got back he'd just watch it over and over
again.
So he knew every little detail.
Yeah.
And that's what you want to do that it's so important to know where you are.
And understand the terrain.
Okay.
Now we're going to talk about something.
It's,
it's a,
it's a French word and I don't speak French by the way.
I dig it.
I looked it up,
but I'm still gonna murder it.
All right.
I apologize.
Here it cute.
It looks like coop doughy oil,
but the way you actually say it is [inaudible].
Okay.
So Cody on,
it's actually used quite a bit.
So I had to like run a couple rehearsals it,
how do you spell it?
C O,
U.
P which,
which I knew that one,
right?
[inaudible] right.
There's a coup and then d apostrophe,
O,
e I.
L.
E coup.
Yeah,
and sometimes they say that a coup de,
but I liked her that some people put a little on the end of it.
I liked that because it made a little bit more distinct.
So that's what I'm doing.
Okay.
And what that means it it,
it translates directly I believe,
to stroke of the eye.
And what it means is like a quick glance.
Oh,
Cody,
you,
so you just take a quick glance at something and you understand it.
Think about the power of this recruiting.
You have a general is the talent which great men have of conceiving in a moment
all the advantages of the terrain and the use that they can make of it with
their army.
When you are accustomed to the size of your army,
you will soon,
you soon form your cutea with reference to it.
And Habit teaches you the ground that you can occupy with a certain number of
troops.
So what are you saying there is you've gotta practice,
you gotta practice,
practice,
practice and that's what,
that's what makes you good at it.
You start to be able to size things up,
right?
You start to look at situations and the more you get put in those situations,
the better you can size them up.
Thinking about when you first started as a bouncer,
right?
When you first started as a bouncer and you'd look at something and you might
think,
oh,
what's this Guy gonna do?
And then a year,
how long were you were bouncer for sort of been here.
Okay.
So by like the sixth year you're looking at a situation like,
okay,
I can see that guy's good,
I got to get that guy out of here.
You,
you just get better at your job.
Yeah.
Your,
your quota,
you,
your way of just looking at things and assessing him get sharper.
Yup.
That's very important.
Oh,
speaking of which,
back to the book,
the Cutea is of great importance.
On two occasions.
The first is when you encounter the enemy on your march and are obliged to
choose ground on which to fight instantly.
As I've remarked with a single square mile,
a hundred different orders of battle can be formed.
This is why you are her,
so this is also why you think you think about when you're patrolling,
you're looking around at the terrain and you're going,
okay,
if we get contacted from over there,
we can go into this direction.
If we get contact from over there,
we can get covered behind this,
this berm,
or go behind this building.
If you're thinking about that,
even when you go into,
yeah,
you go into a restaurant and you're like,
okay,
where are the exits?
That's exactly what you're doing.
Where are the exits?
If someone comes in the front,
here's what I'm gonna do.
If someone comes in the back,
here's what I'm going to do.
You just do a quick assessment.
That's all I'm saying.
Little [inaudible],
the clever general perceives the advantages of terrain instantly.
He gains advantage from the slightest.
Hey look from a tiny marsh,
he advances or advances or withdrawals a wing to gain superiority.
He strengthens easily either his left or his right moves ahead to the or to the
rear and profits from the Marist.
Bagatelles had to look that word up,
by the way.
What is it?
Bagatelle Bagatelos it's something of little value.
So what he's saying is if you're good,
you look at even like a little bag of towel,
just something that's kind of meaningless and you can take advantage of it.
Yeah.
Hmm.
If you think about in Jujitsu,
when a guy,
if you're good at Jujitsu and a guy moves his arm just a little bit like her
cry,
I always say like across the center of their chest.
Yes.
If they do that,
they,
that's only an inch.
Right.
To be like,
here,
I'm okay here.
I'm not okay.
Yeah.
When you're good,
you can take advantage of that.
That's a good example by the way.
He liked it.
Yeah.
So a little Jujitsu at echo make you happy.
It makes me happy to
back to the book to kick the cooter Ya is required of the general when the enemy
is found in position and must be attacked,
whoever has the best cutea will perceive at first glance that weak spot of the
enemy and attack them there.
The ladder is a result of experience
and you can only get experienced through through two things.
Training or actual experience.
Talk about that at the monster.
Yes.
Like if you want to be good you can get good through experience.
Yeah.
Or you can get good through training.
Now there's some things that only experience will give you.
Yeah.
You can really make up a lot of ground just from training.
Good.
Like realistic training.
Really cute.
Yeah.
That's what separates the old martial arts.
Yes.
From the new martial arts through it.
This is the experience.
What's the experience?
Didn't used to be close to a real fight.
Oh,
the training.
Yeah.
The old training experiences didn't,
wasn't close to real fight.
Yes.
It was like Kata and remember those old things where it's like,
well when I hit you here it's going to cause this reduced 100% yeah.
That's like part of the practice.
Let me teach you the reactions that you will have.
Yeah,
that's total garbage and actually that's a good way to kind of evolve.
Good.
A good way to evaluate when someone's like,
okay,
this is how you deal with this attacker or whatever situation and then they
demonstrate it and then it takes a big involvement in like big involvement from
the the tacker person.
Yeah.
You know,
in the demonstration it's like Whoa,
that might not happen.
I remember there was people teaching me that if you hit someone in the neck with
like a karate chop,
a straight up,
they were teaching me this.
If you hit someone in the neck,
it's gonna Knock 'em out.
That's what they were saying and that was part of it was part of the whole
thing.
If you get them here Booman wait a minute,
and I was young and I didn't even know Jujitsu at the time,
but I've been a lot of fights.
When I was a kid.
Yeah.
You know,
we were in the streets and I was like,
I don't think that's actually going to work.
Do it to me
and the dude's karate chop
and me in the neck.
It didn't,
it didn't have any,
I didn't do anything.
I mean does it give you a little flash?
I mean it gives you a look like a little tiny.
He's trying to knock me out now cause I'm calling them out.
Right.
So he's given it all.
Yup.
So there are debunked.
Yeah.
Debunked real quick.
You know those ones where the,
wait,
what was it in the front?
Right side of the neck.
Man Side of the neck.
That's going to knock you out.
He told me.
Yeah.
You know those ones where it could be the same thing where they hit,
they do it.
It's like a karate chop or so and the hitch put this little bit in the front of
your neck and I always see it.
I've never seen it in real life.
Well they do it and they hit you right there and the guy knocks out.
That's not true bro.
It's so that doesn't work.
I've never seen it with Joe Rogan.
Joe Rogan is post something that's like fake [inaudible] and,
and those are slapstick.
I know.
But he's like,
I could literally post these all day long because there's so many of them out
there and they're kind of funny.
It's weird though when you start talking about how when Jujitsu first came
around and people had been training in,
you know,
calling whatever traditional martial art for 20 years and all of a sudden like a
white belt or a blue belt in Jujitsu would come and wrap them up.
Now I will say this,
if I trained whatever,
some traditional martial art and it's 1986 and you and I get in a fight.
Yeah.
I don't know anything.
Yeah,
you're going to be in trouble.
Cause I at least know how to throw a punch.
Yeah,
possibly.
Well,
I mean there's advantages to hitting mitts.
You don't like him for sure.
Punch.
You know how it feels to land a punch that spacial kind of.
Yeah.
Do you have you developed learn how to develop power?
Well,
if we're talking about boxing,
that's a whole different story cause that's a real martial art.
And if you've watched people trained,
they're going to get knocked out sometimes.
But even like a karate situation,
like a guy who can kick a bag,
like that guy does know how to by the way.
And there's some forms of karate.
What does it?
Um,
yeah,
there's some forms of Krave that are legit and they,
they go get after it.
That's what GSPS background was originally in Oak Hill.
She can,
yeah,
it's rough.
It's rough.
No head strikes though.
No head strikes but kind of a bummer.
Yeah,
I mean I think it's like,
Hey,
I'm going to grab the Geek,
grab your g and kick the crap out of your legs and I didn't punch you in the
chest.
It's tough though,
man.
It's,
well,
let's say this,
it's a little bit closer to real,
right?
So it's a little bit closer to real.
That's why it has some effectiveness.
The more closer you are to real,
the more effective something is.
And that's the way it goes.
Yes sir.
Alright.
Right.
Speaking of training back to the book.
It is on this exact knowledge of the terrain that is regulated,
the dispositions of the troops and the order of battle of the army,
so he's,
again,
he's still talking
about being able to look quickly and assess how you're going to set up your
troops on the terrain.
Our modern formations for combat for the most part are defective because they
cast all in the same mold as I really liked this part.
He's saying,
look,
it's not always the same.
The what we do,
what we say right now is,
hey,
everyone lines up here.
Reality is that doesn't work.
We can't do that.
If an army is really to be camped according to the rules of war,
it is essential that each arms should be placed in a locality where it can act.
That means you got to have flexibility in what you're doing.
That's what it means.
Now he talks about
detachments,
how and why they should be made.
There is an ancient rule of war that cannot be repeated often enough.
Hold your forces together,
make no detachments,
and when you want to fight the enemy,
reassemble all your forces and sees every advantage to make sure of your
success.
This rule is so certain that most of the generals who have neglected it have
been punished promptly.
So he's saying don't separate your forces.
And we,
I've talked about this before because that's what I believed.
Are there times where you separate your forces?
Yes,
there are.
You have to be prudent.
You have to be smart.
And He,
well,
here's the dichotomy.
He says the same thing.
The subject of detachments is extremely delicate.
None should be made except for good reasons,
right?
None should be made except for good reasons.
If you're acting offensively,
an open enemy country and our only master of some strong point.
So
again,
this is something I talk about all the time.
Once you've got your s forces separated on the battlefield,
it can get problematic very,
very quickly.
So keep your forces consolidated as much as you can.
How does that translate into the business world?
Well be careful when you start breaking off little chunks,
chunks of your company to go and explore new territory because when you break
off chunks and you get a little bit weaker,
so don't do that.
Well when you do it.
I'm not saying don't do it.
He's not saying don't do it.
When you do it,
understand the risks that are being taken.
That's what you have to do.
Yeah.
And that's good.
It is funny like you,
you kinda how you said that where it's like no,
you know,
basically the idea that it's like this is the hard and fast rule,
but yeah.
You know kind of thing.
Yeah.
That is a good way to put it because if you don't say it like that or you don't
present it like that,
it kind of in a way makes you think,
why can bend that rule then,
you know?
And it kind of,
it's like to the people might be too cavalier cavalier about the whole thing
about making the exception,
you know?
You're right.
I've got a question for you.
How does this apply to,
did
you Jitsu
like what a specific move.
Okay.
So actually use your example,
which has stuck with me from the first time you said it,
by the way,
that don't don't
your elbow across your midline of your body,
your mail list,
like we were going from the game.
You're like,
okay,
see you gave an example of this,
but okay,
so the you,
uh,
you should never put your arm across your chest.
You should never do it
every once in a while.
And I'll almost say not even every once in a while I'll just say there is an
exception where you know,
and I think you had a situation with deans where you were like,
he messed you up,
but you thought about it.
Yeah,
no,
no.
He told me later,
Oh,
here you have to do something that I've told you never to do.
Here.
You have to do it.
It's from the mouth.
It's from you.
Turn so far that you,
that there's an escape.
Where I was going when I was going to talk about this.
Well,
the way the did to just do this specifically,
you're talking about something else that does apply to Jiu Jitsu.
This applies to Jujitsu.
Picture this,
you're,
you're a one body,
right?
When you're doing Jujitsu,
it is highly advantageous to keep your arms and your legs close to your body,
especially your arms,
right?
You don't stick your arm out,
What happens when you stick your arm out?
It's out there by itself and it's taken over.
It's our mock tests get taken over yet.
So,
so you don't do that.
You can,
you keep your arms in close to your body.
And that's where you,
Fabio,
Fabio Santos,
he used to say,
make like your arms come out of your belly.
Oh yeah.
You don't even have shoulders.
Your elbows just come out of your belly.
That's how you should keep your arms.
And I,
I've always obeyed that rule.
Accept there are times when yes,
you got to reach out and you got to make another move happen.
So as much as you can,
you keep your forces consolidated as a body,
as a human.
Occasionally you got to step on that.
So,
but yeah,
if you,
when you put it like that,
it's a,
it's pretty clear that it's like,
hey,
this isn't like some ambiguous rule.
That's the rule.
Keep,
keep your arms in.
That's the rule.
And then remember the golden child you ever watched the golden child anywhere
for,
this is called the golden child,
this old school eighties movie.
But he was like,
hey,
stay on the path.
He was like,
hey,
you got to walk on these like stumps in the dark and get this glass of water,
this Buddha thing I think.
And he's like,
Hey,
stay on the path.
You got to stay on the path.
That's it.
That's the only advice I can give you.
I think there's something else.
But that was it.
So he stays in the bath,
right?
Then there's this weird rope bridge and he,
right as he gets off the rope bridge burst into flames and he's like,
Hey,
I thought you told me to stay on the path.
And he said,
yes,
but you got to know when to break the rules there.
That's it.
Right?
Epic lessons learned from Eddie Murphy,
Murphy Golden Child.
True.
Very true.
All right,
so no problem.
We can come up people from different angles that I'm sure there's someone,
this isn't a podcast,
it was like,
oh,
now I get it.
It's true.
Whoever you are out there,
Echo Charles has got your back.
Okay.
All right.
Uh,
this is a great section.
This is a great section.
The talents that a general must have.
And then it talks about
spies and reduces and stratagems of war.
But here we go.
Talents that a general must have a perfect general,
like Plato's republic is a figment of the imagination,
either would be admirable,
but is not characteristic of human nature to produce beings exempt from human
weakness and defects.
The finest medallions have a reverse side.
Dang,
I liked that.
So yeah,
there's no such thing as a perfect leader and everyone has weaknesses and,
but then he says the finest medallions have a reverse side.
And I don't know if you remember me saying this,
I've said it before.
I'll say it again.
Oftentimes people's biggest strength is also their biggest weakness,
right?
So if you've got a guy that's super aggressive and that's what makes him such a
good for a certain job,
they also can be too aggressive.
And so there's a bunch of examples like that,
but the finest medallions have a reverse side.
Even if you think about what your personal best quality is like you gotta watch
out because it can be out of balance if you,
if you let it go too far.
Now he says this,
but in spite of this awareness of our PIR imperfection,
it is not less necessary to consider all the different talents that are needed
by an accomplished general.
These are the models that one attempts to imitate and which one would not try to
approach if they were not presented to us.
So he's like,
hey look,
even though we can't be perfect,
we should still look and see what perfect is so that we can at least try and get
there.
Nothing wrong with that.
Here we go.
Okay.
It is essential that a general should dissemble while appearing to be occupied.
So what he's saying is you got to detach a little bit working with the mind.
And working with the body and he goes into a good list right here.
Ceaseless least suspicious while affecting tranquility.
So you act like you're calm,
but you should constantly be suspicious of what is happening.
Here's a solid one,
saving of the blood of his soldiers and not squandering it except for the most
important interests.
Take care of your people,
informed of everything that makes sense.
Always on the lookout to deceive the enemy.
And careful not to be deceived himself.
Makes sense in a word.
He should be more than industrious active,
an indefatigable
not forgetting one thing to execute,
execute another and above all,
not despising those sorts of little details which pertain to great projects.
So you gotta be more than just like hardworking.
You gotta be more than active.
And he goes into a little clarity around some of these.
Here we go back to the dissimulation of the general consists of the important
art of hiding his thoughts.
Now this is,
this is one of those things where people start to freak out a little bit
because,
because these days,
everyone throws around the transparency word hi,
everyone should be transparent.
It's like actually no,
you,
you shouldn't be transparent all the time.
Yeah.
And in fact,
you know,
that's why I talk about controlling your emotions all the time.
And that's why it's so powerful.
If,
if,
if you're getting mad at someone and you show them that you're getting mad,
well then you're giving away your hand and now they're going to get mad at you
and it's just a problem.
So you need to,
you need to not do that.
You need to not be transparent.
Yeah.
And this,
he goes into brilliant explanations as to why you can't just be transparent,
hiding UDB hiding his thoughts.
Okay.
He should be constantly on the stage and should appear most tranquil,
most tranquil when he is most occupied for the whole army.
Speculates on his looks,
on his gestures and on his mood.
So when you're walking around and you're panicking,
guess what?
Everyone on the team is looking at you going,
what's going on?
Why is the boss panicking?
Yeah.
If you seem to be more thoughtful than customary,
the officer's will believe he is incubating some project of consequence.
If his manners uneasy,
they believe that affairs are going badly and they often imagine worse than the
truth.
You gotta stay calm.
You've got to put on,
you've got to put on the little mask over your little emotions.
Okay.
And he says the,
these suppositions become the rumors of the army and this army gossip is certain
to pass over to the enemy's camp.
It is necessary,
therefore,
that the personal conduct of the general should be so well reasoned that his
dissimulation will be so profound that no one can ever penetrate it.
Okay?
If he fears that he cannot master his expression.
So no one should ever know what you're thinking
unless you want them to know that.
Right.
Unless you want to give it to him.
Cause I say this all the time,
you can't just be without emotions.
Yeah,
you can.
If you,
if,
if you come to me and you're all mad,
I just can't be like calm down.
No,
I can't do that yet.
I need to,
I need,
yeah,
I need to give you some of that.
Yeah.
So I'm not saying never be emotional,
but you better control them.
They better be the you want to show.
Yeah.
And then he says this,
this is funny
talking about the,
uh,
the general,
if he fears that he cannot master his expression,
either he can pretend to be ill or he should make an excuse to some personal
trouble to explain his appearance to the public,
you know?
Yeah.
That's pretty funny.
That's actually a,
when you think about it,
like a lot of us kind of do that,
like,
uh,
you know,
I'm just tired or something like that.
You know?
Like if like if a girl's crying or something or something like this.
Oh No,
I just had something in my eye.
It's kind of the same thing.
They're like,
oh,
I'm getting dusty in here.
There's something else wrong with me that's understandable.
You know,
it's not me crying or nothing.
Yeah.
I was going to bring up an excuse,
but that's different.
You don't want to use for your,
you know,
when you're doing Jujitsu with someone and they're like,
yeah,
you know,
I just got,
that's all you hear.
Big excuse,
excuse,
excuse.
Don't tell me that.
But that's,
that's interesting advice that shows you how important it is if you're,
if you're willing to like skip work because you don't want people to see your
freaking out.
I don't recommend that.
But Hey,
I can't come into the damn sick.
Yeah.
I think opposite actually happens.
Hung over.
Yeah,
we'll definitely look at it.
You know what,
uh,
people in the teams,
I would say people do the opposite and they have like problems at home.
Instead of my calling and saying like,
Hey,
I can't make it say what they're really doing is like crying because they were a
big scrap what their old lady.
All right.
Uh,
this is,
this is brilliant right here.
Above all,
when he has received some bad news,
he should treat it as a trifle and show the number of resources which he has to
retrieve it.
It's basically good.
That's,
that's saying good when somebody,
what do you have when you received some bad news?
Oh,
good.
Bring it.
He's saying the exact same thing
while never despising his enemy in the bottom of his heart.
He should never speak of him except with scorn and compete.
And compare carefully the advantages of our troops over the others.
Hmm.
So he's actually saying,
look,
he's doing the opposite.
He's like,
I don't even hate my enemy,
but I'll never let anyone know that I don't completely despise him.
Right,
right.
That's pretty funny.
This is good.
If some detachment is unfortunate in the war,
he should examine the cause and after having determined the reason for the
fault,
he should instruct his officers concerning it in this fashion,
a few minor misfortunes,
we'll never discourage the troops and they will always preserve the feeling of
confidence in their ability.
So when something goes wrong,
you don't freak out.
You just look,
okay,
well let's take a look at what went wrong there and then we'll fix it and then
it won't be a problem anymore.
That's how you handle a problem when someone doesn't do well.
Back to the book.
Secrecy is so necessary for a general that the ancients have even said that
there was not a human being able to hold his tongue.
But here's the reason for that.
If you form the finest plans in the world but divulge them,
your enemy will learn about them and then it will be very easy for him to Perry
them.
The general plan of the campaign should be communicated at most to the officer
responsible for supplies and the rest of the details should not be told to
officers except when the time has come to execute them.
When there are generals detached and you must write to them,
the letters should be completely in code.
If your enemy intercepts one,
you will not have betrayed yourself.
This is clearly something that applies to that type of warfare back in the day,
but it applies to life as well.
I mean when you opened your mouth you might as well just,
you might as well just put it on Twitter cause everyone's going to know about
it.
Yeah.
The kind of wear and they always say before they say something of consequence,
they'll say,
hey,
don't tell anyone this but hey,
I'm going to do this or I feel this or whatever and then sure enough they go and
it's the same thing.
Hey,
I'm not supposed to tell you this,
but you know Blah Blah Blah and then yeah,
sure enough that's bad.
Bad,
bad,
bad.
Completely just got told.
I'm not supposed to tell you this.
Yeah,
that's why.
Because you don't say those old hardcore band park and then I think lizard,
I think it was wrecking crew from Boston and they used to have tee shirts.
Just big letters on the tee shirts on the back.
Trust no one
I hadn't won.
Yeah,
that actually sounds familiar.
Like I might have seen a shirt like that before.
I don't know if you saw that shirt.
Maybe other people made it cause they probably,
there's probably like 12 of those turns back.
Echo Charles would have seen on the island of Hawaii can 88 probably not loose
lips sink ships.
So we do say that you are correct
back to the book.
It is absolutely necessary to change your methods often end to imagine new
decoys.
If you always act in the same manner,
you will soon be interpreted for you are surrounded with 50,000 curious who
wants to know everything that you think and how you are going to lead them.
That's pretty cool.
It's interesting.
What,
what's kind of interesting about that is he's not even talking about the enemy.
He's talking about your own people.
You know,
you got to think of new things.
Um,
and this is clearly,
this is something I always try to explain people in Jujitsu is the thing that
you're going for is not going to work.
You,
you have to use the,
you have to use,
create new decoys.
You have to try new things or else you're not going to catch people.
It's a way it works.
Now here we get nick,
I'm glad that I'm the Lafe and I just got done writing a book called the
dichotomy of leadership because here we go.
The commander should practice kindness and severity
should appear friendly to shoulders,
speak to them on the march,
visit them while they are cooking.
Ask them if they wellcare Ford and alleviate their needs.
If they have any officer's without experiencing war should be treated kindly.
They're good.
Action should be praised.
Small request should be granted them and they should not be treated in a manner,
in an overbearing manner,
manner.
So there you go.
It's like that's all good,
right?
That's the kindness part.
Yeah.
Which we're,
we're down with that.
And that's again,
that's why when I talked about why people would listen to this guy,
one of the reasons,
cause he took care of his people.
Yeah.
He was out there seeing what problems they had.
How can we get those problems fixed
and then he says,
but severity is maintained about everything regarding the surface.
The negligent officer's punished.
The man who answers back is made to feel your severity by being reprimanded with
authoritative error.
That superiority,
Gibbs,
pillaging or argumentative soldiers or those who,
whose obedience is not immediate,
immediate should be punished.
So there you go.
Dichotomy.
You got to hold the line,
but at the same time,
don't hold that line so tight that it snaps,
which you can do.
The general can even discuss the war with some of his core commanders who are
the most intelligent and permit them to express their sentiments freely and
conversation.
So when I was talking about how he was just,
everyone listened to me,
blind obedience is water.
Recard here he's saying,
no,
actually listened to your people.
If you find some good things among what they say,
you should not remark about it then,
but make use of it when this has been done,
you should speak about it in the presence of many others.
It was so and so who had this idea?
Praise him for it.
This modesty will gain the general,
the friendship of good thinking men.
And he will more easily find persons who will speak their sentiments sincerely
to him.
Boom.
So that thing,
that macho thing at the beginning was not true.
This is what's true.
Yeah.
You wanna you wanna have,
he's,
the reason that he's doing this is because he wants people to speak their mind
to him.
That's the reason why he's doing this.
Okay.
Think about that.
It's also,
it's also interesting that,
cause I've,
I say this,
you're heard me talk about how like it's whenever someone's right and I'm wrong,
I'm happy because if you're right and I'm wrong,
I can be like,
yeah man,
I call it,
that's a really good job.
And that's really pointed that out.
And it,
it shows you that I'm humble.
Yeah.
Cause otherwise you're just like,
God dude,
Jack thinks he's right off of,
no,
heck no man.
You're right.
I'm wrong.
That's good job.
Hey,
appreciate you,
uh,
straighten me out on that,
right?
Yes,
you are
right,
actually.
Yeah.
And so that's what he's saying is it actually gives you the opportunity to be
modest and to be humble.
Yeah.
Because sometimes it can be hard when you're sure.
Right.
All the time.
Yeah.
And you're used to that feeling and yet,
and the reason I think it's kind of funny cause I can imagine or I can kind of
remember a few times where you're like,
yeah,
you are correct.
You are crying.
You'll say that you are correct.
It won't be like,
I'm kind of happy when you're right.
That's what I feel.
I feel like,
yeah,
I to talk just a little something.
Just not small,
small,
but it's there.
It's something.
I don't know.
It's like,
all right,
well that's,
that's one of the one on the tactics I guess,
but it's still work.
So I guess my overheads that,
am I over here just manipulating you,
put it this way.
I'm glad to be here.
You know?
So,
and that helps that question for you,
and we've talked about this before,
if,
if the reason I was doing it was so that I could get something out of you,
right,
that would benefit me and not benefit in hurting you,
then yeah.
To be manipulation.
But if it's like,
hey,
we're just trying to build,
we're trying to make something happen.
Yeah,
yeah.
Then it's all good in my opinion.
Kind of gives me room to talk to,
which is empowering,
you know?
Sure.
Hey,
I abuse it from time to time.
I understand birds.
There was,
would you say the last podcast was an example of that?
It was bordering on abuse.
I got dressed.
I brushed against the line
over the line.
No real it was it the body,
my body moving through space,
what it was.
I drink some of that discipline and I was on that white tea is listen to this.
I'm just saying,
you know what you need to do right now.
Own it.
The white in business one that I got your brain firing correctly.
I think you are correct.
We're going to cut you off.
There can be like don't give them anymore.
I told you I've been pounding that stuff.
That can,
Woah.
All right,
well let's tasty.
No.
Did a simulated under simulated.
Back to the book.
The principal tasks I ask of
the general is mental large projects and major arrangements,
but since the best dispositions become useless,
if they are not executed,
it is essential that the general should be industrious to see whether his orders
are executed or not.
Again,
just cause you say go make this happen,
it doesn't mean it's going to happen.
You've got to get out there and make sure it happens.
Moving on,
here's a,
here's a line.
You can just,
you can just,
you can just print this up.
Skepticism is the mother of security.
That's legit.
Even though only fools trust their enemies.
Prudent person's never do the generals,
the principal's sentinel of his army.
Think about that.
The general is the principle sentinel of the army.
The guy that's the guy that's keeping everyone safe is the general.
He's the primary watch stander for everyone.
He should always be careful of its preservation and that is
never exposed to misfortune.
One falls into a feeling of security after battles when one is drunk with
success and when one believes the enemy completely disheartened.
Yeah,
so we all know that.
You know when that happens.
You know what Jeff Higgs told me?
If you tap a guy out,
like if it's,
if you have someone that like legit,
you have,
you have battles with on the map and you tap them out,
you,
you need to step it up.
What?
They're going to step it up.
Bringing in a year,
I'll relax.
You're all celebrating your victory.
Don't do it.
Step it up.
They're coming hard.
Yeah,
you do that to me all the time.
Yes sir.
Can I
please get crazy?
Hey,
back to that.
The one you were saying before this about,
you know,
how like you let them talk or whatever the opposite of that is if,
if you know,
let's say when he subordinates or whoever like says something to you and then
you respond with the opposite of what you do with this either tone or words that
basically say,
Oh,
I already knew that you already knew that.
You don't have to tell me kind of thing.
I already knew that people will do that.
You can just on a real small,
even on a social level sometimes and it does make you not want to talk to them
that much.
Yeah,
for sure.
The um,
the idea of saying I already knew that is not good.
Yeah,
that's an extreme case
Tom can say.
But also I already knew that you didn't know it.
If you would've known it,
you would've said it most likely,
like that's an 80% sure.
20% of the time you might be like,
Hey Jocko arm locks work from the garden too.
I'd be like,
I would even then,
I wouldn't say I already knew that.
I'd be like,
yeah,
that's definitely good to consider.
Yeah,
no,
that's sort of a general principle that I totally agree with.
You know,
something like that.
Just not,
I already knew that,
or we'll of course,
or,
or you know,
de that's extreme,
but well,
of course that's the one where they're like,
you know what forces those words out of your mouth,
your ego.
It's your ego because you don't want that person to have that piece of
information that you didn't have.
So I already knew.
Yeah.
It's hard.
I mean,
I can't say that it's not natural.
it feels,
you know,
especially if you did already know it,
it's like,
oh,
I don't want him to think that.
I didn't know that one.
I really did kind of thing.
Like I don't want him to think I'm like not know.
What you need to do is you need to trust,
you need to trust the nature of the world tens.
The nature of the world is that you will eventually be seen as someone that
actually does know that.
Yeah.
Clearly,
you know that trust the nature of the world,
that's the nature of the world.
All right.
Here's another situation.
One falls into a feeling of security.
When a skillful enemy amuses you with pretend piece proposals,
one falls into a feeling of security by mental laziness and through lack of
calculation concerning the intentions of the enemy.
Mental laziness just say no to the mental laziness to proceed and it,
and now he gives instructions on how to overcome these situations to proceed
properly.
It is necessary to put oneself in his place and say,
what would I do if I were the enemy?
What project could I form?
Make as many as possible of these projects?
Examine them all and above all,
reflect on the means to avert them.
Yeah,
if you find yourself unable,
okay,
put it right at once.
So look it even when you win and go,
okay,
well,
if I were the enemy,
what would I do right now?
And if you can't figure out how to solve what you think the enemy is going to
do,
then correct it right now.
Okay.
Often through an hour's neglect and unfortunate delay loses a reputation that
has been acquired with a great deal of labor.
Always presume that the enemy has dangerous designs and always be four handed
with the remedy.
So you got to be careful of what the enemy is going to do.
You've always got to imagine that the enemy is ready for you.
Gotta be ready for that.
That's gotta be your mindset.
And that's an extreme mindset.
Like the enemies always waiting and ready and you can go too far with that
mindset.
There's a dichotomy and here's the dichotomy of it back to the book,
but do not let these calculations make you timid.
Hmm.
So just cause you're thinking about the enemy might do this,
the enemy might do this and but yet could overwhelm you mean like,
you know what?
Screw it.
I'm not going to do anything.
Yeah,
no,
don't let these calculations make you timid.
Circumspection is only good to a certain point.
Okay.
A rule that I practice myself and which I have always found good,
is that in order to have rest,
oneself is necessary to keep the enemy occupied.
If you want to rest yourself,
you've got to keep the enemy occupied.
Got God.
Put your competitive,
you've got to put your competitor on their heels.
If you want to get any restaurant,
you got to put your competitor on their heels.
Then he says this throws them back on the defensive and once they are placed
that way,
they cannot raise up again during the entire campaign.
You just go,
you,
when you get that lead on someone,
you put them down.
That's one of the thing I noticed in MMA.
Like someone will say,
Oh,
you won that last round.
You got this.
No,
no,
actually don't say that to your corner.
Yeah.
You like,
Hey,
that guy's going to step it up.
He's going to come out harder.
This is the round that he's wanting.
He's coming after you.
You need to step it up.
You didn't win that round.
Especially in MMA.
You never know who won the round because the judges are so horrible.
Kidney.
Okay.
Continuing on back to the book.
If you wish to be loved by your soldiers,
husband,
their blood and do not lead them to slaughter.
So that's a,
that's an obvious statement,
right?
But he talks about that in detail.
That's important.
They can be spared by shortening the battle by means that I shall indicate by
the skill with which you choose your points of attack in the weakest localities,
in not breaking your head against impracticable things,
which are ridiculous to attempt in not fatiguing the soldiers uselessly and
inspiring him in sieges and battles.
Okay,
so he's saying you got to take care of your,
your men.
You've got a husband,
their blood and not lead them to slaughter.
But the way you do that is by attacking the week locations is I,
you know,
how many times do you hear me say like,
don't blink.
Bang your head against the wall.
47 times.
Yeah,
47 okay,
that's the limit.
Or 48 you've got to find a different way.
That's what he's saying.
Don't just keep banging your head,
banging your head against impracticable.
Things don't do that.
And here he says this,
when you seem to be most project goal of soldiers,
blood,
you spirit,
however,
by supporting your attacks.
Well,
by pushing them with the greatest vigor to deprive time of the means of
augmenting your losses.
So what is he saying there?
He's saying that the times,
sometimes it might seem like you're being most wasteful,
hmm.
Of of the blood of your soldiers.
But it's in those times where it seems that way,
the weight,
the reason it seems that way is because you're being super aggressive just
because you're,
you're setting up your tax,
you're supporting them well and you're,
you're being default aggressive husband,
their blood that's like take care of care of you.
We'll take care of it.
Like it's like it's yours.
Yup.
Take care of it.
And then be saying,
when you seem to be most prodigal of your soldiers blood,
that means when you're wasteful of your soldiers blood.
Hmm.
You spare it by supporting your tax.
Well that makes sense.
By pushing them with the greatest vigor.
That makes sense.
Cause if you guys are going at it half ass,
guess what's not going to work out well for him?
Hmm.
Your rules of war are of great usefulness or sorry,
Russa's of war are of great usefulness.
Roosters of war,
so this is like tricks,
right?
They are detours.
Listen to this,
they are detours which often lead more surely to the objective than the wide
road which goes straight ahead.
Okay,
so what does he say in there?
Don't do the frontal assault on the enemy's strong point.
Use tricks,
claims flanks and here he just breaks it down.
Animals have only one method of acting,
but intelligent men have inexhaustible resources.
These resources are infinite in number.
Their object is to hide your veritable design and to catch the enemy and the
trap you have prepared for him.
Okay?
Thus the contrary of what one wishes to do is feigned.
If you open the campaign,
you have your troops march and counter march so that the enemy cannot learn the
locality where you assemble.
If it is a question of capturing cities,
you and camp in a place which makes him fearful for two or three cities of his
at the same time being attacked.
If he hastens to one flank,
throw yourself on the other.
This is obvious stuff.
Seems obvious,
but what are you doing when you're,
when you're setting up a triangle,
right?
You're,
you got the arm bar,
you,
you put the person in the threat of the arm bar and the triangle and the sweep
all at the same time.
You,
you,
you set up camp in between three cities and they don't know which one you're
going to attack and they got to defend all of them.
Are they going to try to defend all of them?
So when they hasting to defend the arm bar,
that's when you throw yourself through this triangle,
that triangle,
that triangle
you out with the enemy to force him to fight or to prevent him from it.
So he's saying that the two ways to outsmart the enemy as you either make the
enemy fight when you don't want him,
when he doesn't want to,
or you prevent him from finding when you don't want to fight.
And here he talks,
this is basically a reverse psychology is what he's about to go into right now.
There are two means of forcing the enemy to fight.
One is pretending to fear it.
His self confidence becomes your accomplice security laws him into security
laws,
him and you're cutting triumphs.
So if you act like you're afraid,
maybe the person is going to fight you when it is desired to avoid battle.
Different roses are used and apparent war has made which has all the actions of
the authentic live and which nevertheless is of an opposite nature.
So He's in there.
If you don't want to fight,
you act like you want to fight.
That's that's all he's saying in a bunch of words.
It is your attitude that imposes on your enemy and the suspicion that you give
him that you are forming the boldest prayer projects against him.
The attitude is maintained by not withdrawing easily before the enemy and often
the appearance that you are waiting for him,
we'll make him lose all desire to attack you but if he does kill them,
you steal away by at night march,
which you are already planned long before he thinks he has you and the next day
there's no one.
If you only withdraw,
you will be fought,
followed,
but,
but then it is necessary to take position to the flank,
which will prevent him from passing you without running into great danger.
Okay.
This sort of war is a masterpiece of the Austrians and it is from them that it
should be learned.
So Act aggressively and plan your escape.
That's kind of the key thing because if you just act aggressively,
you might get called on it,
right?
Yep.
And he say to act aggressively,
but plan your escape while you're acting aggressively.
This is going to sound like,
this isn't an example because we all are too familiar with it.
But here's the thing.
When it first came out,
when this tactic first came out,
it was a good example of that very thing.
So at the bark die wants to fight you.
Right?
That's why you want to fight me.
You want to fuck me?
Okay.
Tell your friend,
Hey,
hold me back.
Holding me back.
Right.
You got to fight and yeah,
let's fight.
Let's fight the fight holding me back home.
You're back home in friends,
holding them back.
He wants to fight.
The guy's like,
oh shoot,
this guy wants to fight whatever and be like,
hey,
meet me outside.
We're going to fight outside.
Meet me outside one minute.
I don't want to fight it in here,
you know,
but I'm ready kind of thing.
Cause I thought he goes outside and meets the guy.
It's like guys gone.
You don't get to fight.
Acted all aggressive.
Yeah.
And then when he went outside to fight you,
I'm not even wants to go outside to fight.
You might be like,
man,
this gets kind of crazy.
It was down to fight to all quick.
So I might not go out there,
but when he does finally go out there,
he's gone.
Is it an unwritten rule that if you go to get a fight,
I'm going to try and hold you back?
Could you get like whispered us over like hold me back.
I know back in the day before everyone knew that tactic.
It's kind of like that was a good tactic.
No,
I'm just saying,
is it the general rule to just hold people back?
Like,
hold your friend back from getting in a fight and defend.
Depends on,
I guess,
cause if you ever been with someone who's like I'm not gonna hold you back.
Go.
You want to Oh yeah,
100%.
One of my buddies who's always a Badass team got somebody was talking smack,
another seal was talking smack.
He's like,
I'll go kick that guy's ass.
Yeah.
Thinking that my buddy would be like,
no,
you know,
don't hold your,
hold you back.
Go ahead.
What are you waiting for?
He's right over there.
Why don't you go get them?
You're running your mouth
so they'll run your mouth is the key point there.
Yeah.
See so I feel,
I feel like that's kind of like a response to that old school tactic.
Yeah,
no,
that's a good response to the old school tactic.
If you come out with me and you want to go after someone,
I'm going to let you go.
Let me like go,
go,
go get some,
see what you got.
Cause I don't like people when they're running their mouth.
You know what I mean?
I don't think anyone does.
You know we had a gun or in football too.
It's weird that everyone knows.
No one likes people that run their mouths,
but there's a bunch of people in the world that run their mouths.
Yeah.
Explain that one.
We all know it.
It's Kinda like the name dropping thing,
right?
It's harder to see it in yourself than it is to see another people.
It's like easy to see it in other people.
I hate when they got runs his mouth.
Meanwhile,
like that's all you do kind of thing.
It's hard to see it in yourself.
Easy to see it.
I think that's one of those things.
That's what I think,
but who knows?
Yeah,
good point.
Because that is that you just,
you once again for that guy that's listening,
you just nailed it.
He's like,
oh,
got it.
That I'll tell you what this book was.
I don't know if the translation or whatever,
but there's definitely some long complicated sentences that were a little bit
tricky for me.
I'm sure I had to read a few times
back to the book.
And let me by saying that what I mean is like sometimes you know a movie from
1987 as a better example for him and that was one dazzler.
Good real over here
there is another reus which is that if you find the enemy too strong to attack
him,
you help him with the means of dividing his forces.
So basically if you can get people to split up,
if you can get your enemy to split up,
that's a good tactic as well.
There's another type of reus,
which is admirable.
It is that of double spies.
It is necessary to know them and then tell them with an air of good faith,
everything that you want the enemy to know.
So there you go.
It is essential to know what is happening amongst amongst the enemy.
I'm of the opinion that the best thing against the Austrians would be to bribe
some captain or major for their who?
SARS by means of whom intelligence can be carried on with them.
And there's a reason why I'm talking about this.
So he's talking about spies and this is kind of old school,
but I,
I brought that part up so I could do this part right here.
If greed for silver does not work,
it is necessary to employ fear.
Sees some mayor of a village where you camp and force him to take a disguised
man who speaks the language of the country and under some pretext to conduct him
as his servant in the enemy army
threatened him that if he does not bring your man back,
you will cut the throat of his wife and children whom you hold under guard wall
waiting and that you will have his house burned.
I was obliged to employ this sad expedient in Bohemia and it succeeded for me in
general,
does necessary to pay spies well and not to be miserly in that respect.
A man who risks being hung in your service merits being well paid.
So Frederick the great,
we know he,
we know he liked music and literature,
but guess what?
He was no stranger to just having your family's throat cut and burned the house
down.
Ruthless.
So he seemed be we'll pay like,
it's kind of like,
hey,
if you listen like a carrot and the stick situation where it's like,
okay,
if you listen,
if you're all good,
you get paid well.
If not,
you get your house burned down in a kid's life.
Slit throats.
Yup.
He's saying if no,
he's saying if you can use the carrot,
if the carrot works,
that's great.
If you could make someone greedy,
that's like,
all right,
you know what,
I'll get this information for you because I'm greedy.
That's cool.
If you can't get that
kind of give them no choice kind of situation.
Yeah.
And you know,
that's what's scary about that is that's
goes on today.
That's what a lot of the jihadists would do.
They would,
they would kidnap where they would,
they would take someone and say,
look,
you either run the suicide bomb and this building or we're going to kill your
family,
all of them and burn your house down.
And,
and you know,
the people make that horrible choice and that I will even that,
that's more the stick.
It's like,
remember that's complete stick.
Remember the Ma,
like apparently the on the mafia movies and stuff,
they're like,
hey,
they are paying off this guy.
But if he's like,
if he doesn't want to play the game anymore and then they kill him,
you know,
it's Kinda like that,
right?
Basically.
No,
it's two different things.
So if you can get someone that does,
we'll do what you want him to do for money.
That's great.
Yeah.
If you can't get anyone to do that,
then you got to go.
Yeah.
But I guess you're right that someone could say,
Hey,
I'm done.
And then you go,
oh no,
you're not done.
You're done.
So you are right.
Yeah.
No Mafia.
The mafia thing,
like,
yeah,
you're gonna,
you're going to,
you're going to keep doing this.
No,
not people get involved in situations like that that they shouldn't have gotten
involved in and it all seems okay.
Yeah.
It all seems okay in the beginning,
you know,
one side or the other because either side,
whether you're a criminal or you're,
you're,
whether you go to help a criminal law or you go to help the cops out,
like you think it's going to be,
hey,
it's just going to go good.
It's not,
you're going to up in a bad situation.
You're in a bad way so that the expression,
getting into bed with a whatever,
it's not going to work out.
I never wanted to be a spy of any kind.
You never did never want to be a spy of any kind.
Never watched a James Bond.
And it was like,
I'd really like to do that.
Never watched a spy movie and thought like,
I don't know.
I don't like the,
I don't like that whole
paranoia like undercover cops too.
I'm sure we'll get somebody that can deep undercover never had like,
I don't,
I want to,
I don't like that.
I don't can dig it and I don't like to,
I don't want to fabricate everything like that all the time.
It's just hard.
I mean,
props to them.
Like undercover cops.
That's crazy job.
Can imagine it.
Imagine going in,
right?
You're undercover cover.
You go in and you don't know if like I know
for sure if she needs organized crime bosses,
how it is on the movies anyway,
where when they find out it's like a lot of times they don't just,
Oh,
what really set them up.
Yeah.
That's a,
I never had the desire to do that.
Some people really like that stuff.
I never had the desire to do that and for swordfish,
watch a movie,
swordfish.
That happens.
Anyway,
this is like a cross and a double cross anyway.
Yeah.
We'll talk about that some other tough hour.
You know what?
Let's tee it up from that podcast.
Go back to the book cover
check.
In neutral countries,
it is necessary to make friends if you can win over the whole country so much.
The better the friendship of the neutral countries gained by requiring the
soldiers observe good discipline
and by picturing your enemies as barbarous and bad intentioned,
solid,
solid advice.
Right?
Hmm.
Okay.
Oh,
this is good.
Let no one imagine that it is,
that it is sufficient just to move an army about to make the enemy regulate
himself on your movements
so you,
you can't just think to yourself,
hey,
my moves are enough and I'm doing an and it's going to have the impact that I
wanted to have.
Okay.
A general who is,
who has too presumptuous,
confidence in his skills,
runs the risk of being grossly duped.
That's what this is.
Don't let your ego get out of control.
War is not an affair of chance.
A great deal of knowledge study and meditation is necessary to conduct it well,
and when blows our planned,
whoever can tribes them with the greatest appreciation of their consequences,
we'll have a great advantage.
Yeah.
However,
to give a few rules on such a delicate matter,
I would say that in general,
the first of two army commanders who adopts an offensive attitude almost always
reduces his rival to the defensive and makes him regulate himself on his
movements.
What does that mean?
It means default aggressive.
It means go.
That's what it means.
Unskillful general's race to the first trap set before them.
I just had a guy on Twitter say,
uh,
I'm a white belt but tonight I swept the blue belt.
It wasn't really that good though cause he arm locked me quickly thereafter and
I was like,
sweep him.
You got set up Jujitsu.
So same thing.
Don't race for the first trap that's set before you.
This is why a great advantage is drawn from knowledge of your adversary.
And when you know his intelligence and character,
you can use it to play on his weaknesses.
Okay.
Everything,
which the enemy least six specs will succeed the best.
That's true.
100%.
That's why when you get,
like,
when you think about when you get caught in Jujitsu,
I would say most of the time it's getting caught with something that you didn't
expect.
Right.
Some people,
Dean can do things and like he's going to get it and you know what's coming.
Like you hear Hixon stories Hicks and be like,
I'm going to arm lock everyone's left arm and they'd line up 20 black belts need
our mock everyone's left arm.
Yeah.
But most of the time it's something that you least expect.
In the in,
there's kind of two things.
I think the weird,
strange,
I was just thinking about this
yesterday with,
there's like there's two kind of ways where you'll get caught.
So if you want,
he's dean as the example and then the,
the unexpected example.
If you get caught by someone,
like when Dean does that or does like go,
I'm going to get you with this.
What he does is the equivalent of let's say like,
I don't know,
he might not literally say that,
but you know it's coming.
I mean I do this to you,
right,
where you're like,
oh,
he's good about to come hear me.
Yeah.
Like you know what's coming.
So that's the situation that we're talking about.
Yes.
Example one.
So it's like,
okay,
if you're on the battlefield,
do whatever you have a defense here,
you know,
a defensive position there,
defensive position there.
I defends his position in there and they're all protecting ultimately.
Like one guy's protecting this guy,
this guy's protecting this guy and this guy kind of thing.
So it's like you can't get to this guy with that without going through this
situation.
Right.
And what Dean essentially does is he shuts down all your defenses for this thing
to moves ahead of you.
So it's like,
okay,
I'm going to try to pass the guard,
but to pass the guard,
how's he going to defense?
So he shuts that down before you even realize like,
oh yeah,
that he's going to try to [inaudible] steps ahead.
Yes.
So when he goes for these wound,
I'm getting the commuter on you.
It's not the community itself that got you.
It was
your arm out.
And I isolated it because I was going for a choke and I ended up doing that.
Yes.
And then your other arms tied up under your heaviest knee because that's part of
the defense.
But you already knew that,
but you already knew that.
So they,
you shut those down.
And that's what Dean's good at.
A lot of time,
especially at,
he has that weird good like pressure.
Oh,
you know,
so if your arm is like isolated,
since you don't really detect like immediate threat,
you're like Dang my arm stuck,
but hey that's not,
it's kind of okay for right now.
I'll deal with it later.
But here's the thing,
not you're not going to do it.
He just took care of that,
that big defense that you're going to need by the way,
and it's gone and then by the time you get there,
you don't even know that you need it yet in 20 seconds in the future.
But he already eliminated that.
Exactly right.
And that's the way it works there.
And the other ones are just like how you're saying where it's kind of like you
don't,
you attack this sweep and the arm bar and when they go to defend one or even
both of them a lot of times because they're ready for it,
you know,
you went for the thing that you had planned or dean does that what I like,
let someone try and our mock and more let them try and triangle and they're 100%
not going to harm walk them.
Yeah.
But even me,
I'll be like,
maybe I can get it this time.
He continues on here.
Back to the book.
If you realize for security on a chain of mountains that he believes
impracticable and you pass these mountains by roads unknown to him,
he is confused to start with and if you press him he will not have time to
recover from the his consternation.
That's actually a really good description of Jiu Jitsu right there.
Like you're just confused by the time you're trying to overcome your confusion
and you're concerned,
you're getting crushed in the same way.
If he places himself behind a river to defend the crossing and you find some
Ford above or below,
which he which on which to cross unknown to him,
this will surprise and derange him and confuse him.
I liked that
the art of war is divided between force and stratagem.
What cannot be done by force must be done by stratagem and I actually was kind
of unclear about the usage of the word stratagem and there's meanings of it.
To clarify the meaning a little bit more specifically,
it's means like deception but trickery.
It's not,
it just doesn't mean strategy means like we're,
we're,
this is a trick scenario.
Yeah.
It kind of seemed like the root word of what strategy can and maybe came from,
well,
yeah,
I would definitely say that it's the same day.
So I'd say you failed that one.
Uh,
hold on,
let me Redo that.
That's a good point.
Yeah.
And I didn't see that.
You,
uh,
see sometimes I don't follow my own guidelines.
That was one of them.
Huh?
Talking a dagger at you.
Isn't that an exception though?
Because you know how like everything,
you know,
you can do something too much.
So like,
you know,
like if you're always encouraging me,
I'm busting out dumb,
obvious stuff at all.
Looking at like strategy.
Yes,
exactly.
That's why I didn't try and fake it.
You know,
I kept a real
dichotomy,
check,
uh,
have your disposition supported well,
do not forget your reserves.
Take advantage of the terrain and then attack him.
Brusquely and you should be able to hope for the most brilliant success.
If the heights are on your side,
this will be of great advantage to you.
If they are not,
you have almost no hope of succeeding.
Take the high ground or the high ground.
We'll take you something that we talked about a little bit.
Yes sir.
Now he's talking about Ti attacking the enemy's entrenchments.
So the enemies in a defendant position,
if you have resolved to an attack,
an entrenched enemy,
do it at once and do not allow him to time to perfect his works.
So if you know you're going to have to defense attack a defended position to do
it as quick as you can,
don't let them get their defense is all set up.
That's something that a lot of Jujitsu players,
they
especially,
I would say it's kind of the same thing.
But if you pass my guard,
I don't wait until you settle me across the side before I start escaping.
As soon as I know I'm going to lose that position,
I'm already escaping.
Yeah.
And same thing if I pass your guard and then I let you get in your defensive
position.
Well it's gonna be hard to Yank your arm over there,
but there's a moment where your arms hanging out and if I go for it right then
my probability for success is a lot higher.
I you got all mad one time,
like a couple of months ago because I did that to you.
I like pastor go wham on.
And you and you
were,
it was a straight,
just something that bothered you about it.
Yeah.
Emotionally.
I don't know what it was.
Oh,
I could recount the account.
Yeah.
So I said to you,
I said,
you know what,
because you kept getting me with the guilty and I was,
and I said to you kind of,
I don't even know why I said this,
but I did say that.
I said,
I think I got my defense against your Kimora in arm locked,
like your other arm moves.
I think I got that.
Dot.
I think I'm solid with those,
defending those,
but to guilty and I'm still,
you know,
trying to figure out,
I said something,
I said that basically in so many words and you were like,
oh,
okay.
And then yeah
and yeah,
and then you went a little bit,
you know,
more sense of urgency or whatever and it was an arm bar that you did that was
almost a,
would've been a flying arm barks up.
It was done within a scramble.
So like you kind of did a little guard pass and you went to and yeah,
it came out of nowhere.
You shouldn't have been capable of doing that in my opinion at the time.
I open the game up sometimes I go to open the game up a little bit.
Yes,
he did.
That's exactly,
I love that part of Jujitsu la.
I love that part too,
where you're going like getting after.
I've been training with Andy hard and we've been both been opening up the game.
I used to train with Dean like this all the time.
We just didn't care.
Suicidal.
Every move was a suicide move.
Like,
Hey,
I might just die after I do this move,
but I'm gonna do it anyway.
And you just watch.
It would just be like a,
like a,
like a Tasmanian Devil.
You see stuff going on.
I'm trying to train like that again right now.
Yeah.
And that's good because it's so fun in a way.
You start to,
it's almost like you guys are both doing offense and counters is what you're
doing.
You're not really defending technically much.
Exactly.
You know,
you're just going to Congress and yeah,
he's going for something.
You'll be like,
okay cause most news have a counter to it,
you know,
kind of thing.
And you're just thinking like it's a real forward thinking like dynamic.
Yeah.
Yeah it is.
It's fun.
It's good.
Yeah.
And so point being,
once you get a little advantage on the enemy,
take advantage,
take further advantage of it.
Don't let them reset and resettle.
Go get a little advantage on your competitor.
Go tear him apart.
Attack harder.
Yeah.
It is the generals coup de d'etat that must decide this.
If you attack a bull by the horns,
your task will be difficult.
And perhaps will not succeed at all.
Attack a week.
Positions make sense.
And now he starts talking about,
so when they talked about attacking it,
an entrenchment or a defensive position,
now he's talking about setting up the defensive position and he says,
as I have already said,
and I repeat it,
that I would never put myself in an entrenchment at least unless a terrible
misfortune such as the loss of a battle or a triple superiority on the part of
the enemy forced me to do it.
So he's not going to dig in and try and defend.
He's going to be on offense all the time.
You know,
this is really the,
essentially what the guard is.
People think,
you know,
you shouldn't be on the bottom in the guard.
That's a disadvantage.
It's disadvantage.
You would rather be on top and if you end up in the guard,
well that's because you ended up there by some gross misfortune of your own
doing,
most likely or you're on the person now have there.
Are there some people out there that absolutely have a guard that's so crazy and
offensive that it's be,
it's kind of morphed that a little bit.
Yeah.
Yes,
that is true.
Yeah.
And then that goes along with it.
And there's some people in combat that are so good at defending positions that
they make it.
We'll look at the Russians that there,
their whole strategy is basically pulling guard like,
yeah,
okay.
You come this way a little bit because what's,
where do you spend more gas defending Gardner passing guard,
passing guard.
Me Too.
For sure.
Trying to pass.
God is way more energy.
Draw draws way more energy.
Trying to pass them on to target.
And when you're just,
when you're just holding and you adjust your hips and you adjust your hips,
well that's what the Russians do.
So their guard is just really,
really good.
They tax you a little bit and moved back.
They tax you a little bit,
move back to tax you a little bit,
move back.
And by the time you get there,
you're exhausted.
Hmm.
Interesting.
You get caught.
Um,
if
you are inferior in numbers,
do not despair of winning,
but do not expect any other success than gained by your skill so you can win
when you're outnumbered,
but you better have some serious skill.
There are some generals who maintain that an army and position should be
attacked in the center.
As for me,
I am of the opinion that it should be attacked at the weakest point.
They say that in breaking the center,
you separate the entire army and place yourself in a situation to gain the most
brilliant advantages.
As for me,
I repeat it,
I approve of all methods of attacking provided they are d directed at the point
where the enemy's army is the weakest and where the terrain favors them.
The least
attack,
weak points.
Boom.
This is important.
The defensive positions is gay and he's talking about the defense a little bit
more.
I would choose only on a saleable positions or else I would not occupy them at
all for we have too many advantages in attacking to deprive ourselves of them
gratuitously.
Let me tell you what I took away away from that.
This is something that I do all the time and it's like no big deal.
It's no big deal,
but when you think about it,
it's,
it's important.
I choose.
I would only choose on a salable positions or else I would not occupy them at
all.
What does that mean to me?
What that means is if
I don't know something 100% I don't try and defend it with a hundred percent
strength.
I see this all the time with businesses,
with human beings,
with people.
They are not,
they don't know something 100% but they're going to,
they're going to fall on their sword because of it and it's a total mistake.
There's,
there's very few things that I feel so knowledgeable about and I have such a
good position on that.
My position is unassailable,
so why it doesn't take a,
it doesn't,
it doesn't.
You're not a bad person if you go,
you know what?
I'm not 100% sure on that.
Yeah.
Here's my opinion,
but it's just an opinion.
Yeah.
Look at people that are,
the minute you throw down and you're in a position that is a saleable meaning
you can get your,
your butt kicked.
Well then guess what,
you will,
someone's going to come and do it.
Yeah.
So just keep an open mind.
Don't,
don't hunker down on positions that you're not even sure about.
Yeah,
there you go.
That's all seems logical.
But here's what's hard I think is because usually that's in like some kind of me
against you situate and I'm talking about obviously with just normal people,
usually it's like some sort of a deep aid that you get into with somebody about
something and it turns into this,
okay,
it's me against you.
I'm right.
You're wrong.
Versus you're right and I'm wrong kind of thing.
And it just turns into that.
So now it's like,
no,
it could have some part in their brain kind of thinks,
okay,
if I say,
Hey,
I'm not really sure.
I just gave up the battle.
I just gave up this whole battle that kind of started and we don't start there.
The key part of this is don't start with,
I'm right in your role.
Start with,
you know what,
I'm not too informed about this subject.
Can you fill me up?
And by the way,
the more you talk as we learned,
the more you talk,
the more I know about your position and my position.
Yeah,
I'm going to let you talk.
You go ahead.
But that is given the,
given the fact or given the circumstances that your brain,
your mind isn't in a me against you because you don't walk around in that mode.
That there is,
that there's a,
there's a,
there's a little dichotomy there too.
You don't want to know why because I'm always me against you.
How many against everyone.
But the way I actually win against you is to not defended an unassailable
position.
Yeah.
That's how I actually win.
And you have this thing where you're,
that's,
that's important.
Important as you say.
Yeah.
And that's not to mention how you always have,
well,
you seem to always have this mindset of like the bigger picture,
like a big,
you know how you say like you don't necessarily,
you're not focused on little battles all the time.
You're more focused on the work.
So a little something,
we call it detached.
I don't really care about the thing that you're actually fired up about.
I don't actually care.
You care about a little tiny bit.
I only care about how it's gonna Affect the longterm outcome of this broad
strategy that I'm over here executing.
Yes.
So see how your,
you seem to be always aware of that.
There's the misstep.
I think
that people,
they get,
what do you call it when you get sucked into our district stations?
Yeah,
yeah,
exactly right.
For sure.
That's not an easy thing to just not do.
I'm just not going to do it.
You know?
It's not that easy,
man.
Not for you though.
I get
back to the book,
I have not spoken yet of the reserve.
It should be commanded by a skillful general and it should be placed in a
locality where he can see everything.
So the reason I brought this up is to again,
counteract something that he said in the beginning of the book,
which is right here.
He should act on his own initiative.
And if he sees that one of the wings are in need of help,
he should conduct a reserve there without being called.
So again,
as much as he says,
Hey,
listen to me obey,
that's his macho statement.
The reality is he wants is he wants his reserve leader to step up and make
things happen without being told.
That's decentralized command.
Hmm.
That's how it has to be.
I like this.
What is practiced in armies is done on a small scale with detachments.
So you got your,
you got your big army,
they do the same thing that the little elements out there in the field do.
What's my primary example?
This cupboard move.
So when he says detachments,
he means just means small little al can break off a company,
apple two and a battalion.
Gotcha.
They're out there doing the same thing that the army is doing,
that the big regiment division's doing.
Hmm,
here's a good one.
A battle is lost less,
less through the loss of men than by discouragement.
Remember that one?
The other one,
the man who does things without motive or in spite of himself is either insane
or a fool.
Wars decided only by battles and it is not finished except by them.
Thus,
they have to be fought,
but it should be done,
but it should be opportunity.
And with all the advantages on your side,
concur,
here's,
here's a good little section,
reflections on the hazards and misfortunes of war.
When a general conducts himself with all prudence,
he can still suffer ill fortune for how many things do not cooperate at all with
his labors.
So yeah,
things are going to go bad.
Whether harvest the officers,
the health or sickness of his troops,
blunders the death of an officer on whom he counts,
discouragement of the troops,
exposure of your spies,
negligence of the officers who should rec rec and order the enemy.
And finally,
betrayal.
These are the things that should be kept continually before your eyes,
so as to be prepared for them and so that good fortune will not blind us.
Hm.
You cannot be blinded by good fortune.
You're going to get lucky sometimes.
Hmm.
He goes on and on about this more.
If an important detachment isn't trusted to a man of judgment and if this man
should become sick or should be killed,
there is all your business hung up for.
No one should imagine that sound heads are common in armies.
Yeah.
Guess what?
It's really hard to find good leaders.
Offensive Generals are rare among us.
I only know a few and nevertheless,
it is only to these that this sort of detachment can be entrusted.
He's talking about aggressive.
When he says offensive general,
he means aggressive generals.
People are going to make things happen
so good.
You know,
if you're like a young person or an old person or you're a person listening to
this,
sure.
If you can make things happen.
Yeah.
It's like incredible.
Yeah,
and you will go far in life.
Well,
if you sit back and you wait for things to happen,
it's not good and you won't go far in life.
Nothing is going to just happen because you held your f,
you crossed your fingers.
It doesn't make anything happen.
You have to make it happen.
You have to be an aggressive general.
And they're rare.
There's not,
he said,
you know what,
there's actually not even any competition.
Like there's no competition for it.
Like if you're,
you're there that you are such hide.
If you're a person that can make things happen,
you are in such high demand,
you're going to,
you're going to be set.
Yeah.
There's just not that many people that will make things happen.
And if you're one of them,
you're going to do great.
Yeah,
that's true.
Huh?
Hey,
am I saying they get to step on toes and you've gotta be all aggro and Matt
Macho and run around?
No,
I'm not saying that you make things happen and you do it tactfully and you're
smart.
You the sky's the limit.
Yeah.
Cause it's not like this,
just this overabundance of people making,
Hey,
I work with businesses all the time.
The,
the,
every,
every single business I work with is looking for good people that are going to
make things happen.
Yeah.
That's just all of them.
100% I never went to a business.
They're like,
oh yeah.
Luckily everyone here,
we're maxed out with people that good,
good people that make things happen.
Yeah.
So be a person that makes things happen.
There's a difference
as far as what I can tell,
this is the difference between someone who's grinding and working real hard at
it and then someone who makes it happen.
Cause like,
okay,
when you kind of make it up and sure that usually takes work.
I dig it.
But at the end of the day it's like they're straight up results for sure.
To just work.
Sorry,
the guy that works,
art's cool too,
but there's a difference.
You're right.
It,
there's a difference between somebody that just makes things happen.
Yeah.
And they'll work,
they'll do whatever.
Don't make things happen.
They'll work hard,
they'll grind hard,
don't maneuver.
They'll go back.
They'll read,
they'll read.
They'll revisit the whole plan.
Yeah,
to get the result.
They're going to make it happen.
Remember I told the story about finding wine for my brother?
Go.
You're going to start that.
That was the kind of the I know.
Terrible example.
I know,
but at its core,
it's the same thing.
You ever seen the wine aisle,
it's huge and you're like,
you easily could say,
hey,
I didn't have that much time,
or whatever.
You know,
grind.
I don't care.
I'll be there.
You're one of those people,
I'm sure I'm starting.
I'm beginning to see a series does.
Okay.
Speaking of things happening by luck,
kind of mentioned that in considering for Tutus events and the chapter of
accidents,
one can see that a general should be skillful and lucky and that no one should
believe so fully in his star,
that he abandoned himself to it blindly.
If you are lucky and trust in luck alone,
even if your success reduces you to the defensive,
if you are unlucky,
you're already there.
So if you're counting on luck,
you're already on the defensive and if you're unlucky,
you're already on
and you know what I say to that is make your luck.
That's what I say.
Yeah.
Get out there.
Make your luck.
Yeah,
you will have seen by what I have occasion to delineate concerning war,
that promptness and my prompt us,
he's talking about speed.
Promptness contributes a great deal to success in marches and even more in
battles.
That is why our army is drilled in such fashion that it acts faster than others.
Violence of action is what they used to teach us in the seal teams.
How cool is it when you're 19 years old and you're getting taught about violence
of action?
Seems pretty cool.
If I heard this podcast and I was 18 years old and I heard someone saying,
when you got to the seal teams,
you get taught about violence of action.
I would go sign up with the Vla.
Yeah,
violence of action,
like go hard now.
That's what he's talking about.
He calls it promptness,
but we don't call it God.
Miss Recall,
call violence of action
from drill.
These maneuvers which enable us to form in the twinkling of an eye and from this
that speed in all cavalry moments.
So again,
when I got to the seal teams,
they didn't say,
hey,
you need to learn to be able to move in the twinkling of an eye.
I wouldn't have been would have been dealt with that violence of action.
Yes sir.
That's what's important.
As that was talking about cavalry,
now he talks about on foot as for the rapid step of the infantry and the attack,
it is not,
it is not the greater or lesser number of dead that decides and action,
but the ground you gained,
it is not the fire but the bearing which defeats the enemy.
So we say it's not like the the,
the shooting that does it,
it's how aggressive you are.
And so now there's a caveat to that,
which is like fire superiority is a real thing.
And if you've been on the wrong side of supplier superiority,
you're not winning anything.
But if you get aggressive,
then that is the one of the most powerful things on the battlefield.
And that's exactly how you overcome.
When,
when you're,
when someone else has superior firepower on you or fire superiority on you,
the way you overcome it is by aggressive action,
by sending out someone to a flank and and do something aggressive move.
That's what you have to do.
That's what you do to get out of there and they taught us.
That's another thing they tell us like you get ambushed.
Do you get,
someone's got fired spirit eerie,
what do you do?
You attack,
that's do you attack?
Still recommend that.
A couple more thoughts here from Frederick the great,
the general should make sure that new uniforms for the army arrive in time
towards spring,
that the captains provide shoes,
that the wagons,
Canon carriage is et Cetera of the army are repaired as well as the saddles and
boots of the cavalry in a word.
He should enter into all these details and himself visit the quarters to see
what is going on there.
If the officers are drilling the recruits,
if they are working,
and to animate them with kind words and reprimands to make them do their duty.
So he's a guy that gets in there.
Yeah.
That makes things happen as we've been talking about.
And he's also a person that really takes care of his people,
make sure that they are taken care of.
If you take care of your people,
your people are going to take care of you.
He closes out and close out the Frederick.
The great thoughts right here.
I had to pick something to close on.
There's a lot of stuff,
but I figured this one would,
would do a decent job.
It should be said to the shame of young men that debauchery and laziness often
make them prefer ease
to glory.
Boom.
So
there you go.
And obviously once again,
um,
I think we see that leadership is leadership is leadership and in different
times and different places and different battles in different circumstances,
the fundamental principles do not change.
They do not change it.
And we do see them with different angles and you see different nuances and that
provides us the ability to understand them with greater depth
so that,
so that we can become better leaders.
Is War is what I'm talking about here.
Not,
maybe not,
maybe not as great as Frederick the great,
but if we become better leaders,
we can take better care of our teams.
And if we take care of our teams,
our teams will take care of us.
And that
is what leadership is.
Frederick the great.
Now we make this podcast so that we can learn and I learned a lot from this
podcast myself and we also do it on a podcast so that other people can learn
with us,
which is seems fair.
And if anyone wants to help support the podcast,
it was actually a bunch of different ways that you can do at which we'll talk
about.
And it's not just like,
hey,
just support to podcasts.
That's not,
that's not the deal.
No,
it's more like just get in the game,
get anything.
Yes.
That's the other one.
It's about just support.
The podcast would be,
uh,
send,
you know,
send money or hey,
we're going to put the podcasts
behind a firewall and if you want to get them,
you'll give me money.
That's not what we're saying.
No,
because we're getting a lot of,
oh,
we're already getting a lot out of the podcast.
Yes sir.
So we're good.
But if you want to get deeper into the game,
think that's cool.
You can do that too.
You can do that one way is our company origin USA.
You can do it.
Farmington,
Maine.
What is it?
American made products 100% American made without compromise.
Get some,
we got gies and rash guards,
which are the best in the world.
Straight up straight.
No,
no doubt.
No doubt.
Yeah.
Factually.
Oh,
it's factually the,
the geese are made of a blend.
They're not Ughi from 1956 which is what all other geese are.
Just geeks from 1956 I mean,
yeah,
right.
No,
you're not.
You're a modern,
modern made for Jujitsu.
Yes,
indeed.
Indeed.
Yup.
Yeah.
And also
the joggers.
I know,
but yes,
the joggers most comfortable Joe.
So,
okay.
And you know,
I,
I consider myself a fancy myself as a connoisseur of comfort.
Right?
So I consider myself a connoisseur of suffering.
Yes.
So this,
the,
it's the daikon.
There's a dichotomy even within the podcast personalities.
So if you are interested in that,
I would recommend the joggers.
Yeah,
yeah.
I'm not interested in it.
So if you are interested,
you can get them with not,
oh,
by the way,
you can jog in them too,
by the way.
Okay.
Well then I guess that ups the suffering level a little bit.
He can do suffering in
the comfortable joggers.
That's,
that's kind of the key anywhere.
What else?
Also there's supplements there.
Yeah,
a bunch of different kinds.
Sure.
Yeah.
Joint Weatherford joint supplement one.
So joint warfare is,
and this is totally just me doing this,
me categorizing it.
So the Krill oil,
Iowa,
I always looked at like,
okay,
Omega threes,
that's for general health,
you know,
so joints and other stuff.
By the way,
your eyeballs,
there's stuff too.
Um,
it's going to keep it more in the game,
healthy,
whatever.
So your joints as a degenerate over time.
Boom.
The Omega threes from the Krill oil,
which is the best absorption compared to fish oil and all these other
supplements,
which are fine,
but crow is way better.
Jocko.
Super Krill oil,
even better,
more antioxidants,
by the way.
Factually I always considered those as just general health.
I did.
And so the joint warfare,
that's like if you're getting nuts doing Jujitsu,
that's kind of the thing,
right?
Even when I first started you to Brant,
I think it was,
he was like,
hey glucosomine and can Drayton,
this is going to help you from just from all the twisting that you do,
especially when you train every day,
this is back,
you know,
training five,
six days a week,
hardcore competing or whatever.
And he was like,
yeah glucosomine constraints.
So I always like viewed those two like so the joint warfare has glucosamine,
Chondroitin and Curcumin,
you know that I always got to add the extra good stuff.
Yay.
Yeah,
I dig it.
Good.
So it's like if your joints are being like hammered on,
cause you carrying a pick ax all day or something like this.
Anyway,
that's how I kind of view the thing.
So I had surgery on my bicep.
I know I'm going to go into it again.
I'm gonna give you an update on it.
So literally I'm no cast.
Have no cash bandage,
no stitches,
no nothing right now.
That's amazing.
In fact,
if you see me,
you wouldn't even think,
maybe
I didn't remember that you had surgery until you told me today
I want to do a tench.
But the uh,
the fro,
and that's funny you say that because sometimes I even forget I had surgery.
Like you don't want to like you do just everyday stuff.
Was there anything done?
I'm not going to try and drag this out,
but you had the exact same surgery on the other arm.
The healing process was much,
much slower.
The only,
I guess difference between the two scenarios.
There's actually two differences.
I said the only,
but there's two differences.
One,
you were much younger in your first surgery,
which would indicate that probably you would heal quicker.
Yeah.
But that did not happen and that has not happened.
In fact,
the opposite has happened.
You have healed much,
much faster.
It's not even close much faster.
And the only other thing is that joint warfare,
Krill oil.
That's the only thing I did different.
Yes.
In fact,
yeah.
I mean,
yeah,
it's the only thing I did different.
Um,
to the point I hear it's
in the spirit of accuracy.
I don't know technically,
biologically how much this is healing as far as Mike tendon healing to the bone.
I don't know.
There's no way of knowing,
but I do know this,
I forget that I had surgery three weeks ago by the way,
to reattach my whole muscle,
to my boom.
They drill a hole in your bone.
They put it in that hole.
They put an anchor on the other side of your bone attached to them.
And it's broad.
It's not nothing.
And I forget that I had that surgery three weeks ago,
by the way.
Well,
that's good.
Joint Warfare,
awesome Krill oil.
I've been on that forever and I highly recommend it because it helps you with
everything.
And now you're saying it helps me with my vision too.
Well,
Omega threes helped you with a bunch of stuff in your body,
including vision.
All that stuff's going to know.
I just thought I just had sharp vision
Omega threes men look into.
It's all good.
Also discipline,
you need discipline.
Yeah.
So,
yeah,
just want to be self discipline in your life.
But you're not talking about that.
No,
no,
no.
And it's not even impose the discipline and actually it's kind of somewhat
imposed.
You're imposing on yourself but not really cause you made it tastes go then
supplements called discipline,
but you made it taste good so it's not imposed.
It's welcomed.
It's like well discipline.
Dave and I were up working with a client actually gets to me,
Dave and Lafe and we're up working with a company and you know,
whenever we work,
whenever we get together it's always like we're going hard.
And you know,
there's not a lot of sleep going on or whatever and workouts and all that.
And you ever,
um,
you ever seen those like videos or memes where they got one word that means a
lot of different things.
Like I remember there was an old one about dude and it said like,
oh,
it could mean,
you know,
how's it going?
Like dude.
Or it could mean,
why did you do that?
Like,
Dude.
And the other day I was with Dave and we were at this gig and you know,
like I said,
we're working and he sees me with a cause,
you know,
Dave's kind of addicted to discipline.
Yes.
And he sees me with a,
I took a water bottle,
whatever,
you know,
normal plastic water bottle and I poured discipline in it cause I always travel
with it.
And as I'm,
as I,
I'm now standing with a clear plastic water bottle and Dave sees that I bet it's
discipline.
Right.
And he just looks at me,
he goes Brah
totally knew exactly what he meant.
He wanted some discipline bad.
And I was like,
yeah man,
I got enough for you Dave.
And then he caught on fire on fire.
Cognitively.
Really?
What's cause we were,
well we did some physical stuff in the morning but we didn't take this
supplement for that.
Uh,
it wasn't that hardcore.
It wasn't like we were rolling.
But yeah,
he wanted the cognitive enhancement for putting together all the different
applications of extreme ownership up in the company.
So yeah.
Yup.
No big deal.
And that's what it is.
Ultimately is a cognitive
enhancing supplement,
but Jocko style,
and you know what,
this is the thing that I got to figure out because I've got,
you know,
I've got my own little methodologies of how I operate just across the board.
There's just operations to happening,
right?
That's just how I roll.
For instance,
the discipline on in,
when I go in the field or when I go on a trip,
I have little,
little Tupperware thing that's small and I put it up above.
I got a little elastic band on,
I carry in my travel bag,
whatever.
It's all good.
I haven't figured out how to do this with milk yet,
which is a problem because here's the thing with milk.
Milk tastes freaking good.
And if you don't know what mold because it's,
yeah,
it's got protein in it.
That's awesome.
It's got,
what do they buy?
What are they called pro by?
It's got the whole biotics,
which is awesome.
And I never took those before cause I always thought that that was kind of like
just like a yoga thing.
Right?
But they're not so,
but they,
but they're like,
no,
like you're talking to Brian and Pete there can no owner.
You definitely want to.
So we put them in there and now that definitely your gut will feel better,
but whatever,
I don't care about any of that.
It tastes freaking good.
Right?
And so it gives you the old,
the ultimate like satisfaction.
We know,
let's see,
you have a giant steak,
which I eat a lot of giant stakes.
Have you ever eaten a giant steak and you got done and you were still like,
you know what,
I just want it like something a little bit.
I was,
well,
no,
maybe so I get that way.
What I want.
Maybe it's all those years where I should just get after the mint chocolate chip
ice cream at the end of the night.
And so sometimes that little,
that little five little flashback and I get done with a big steak and I'm a
should be all happy.
And instead I'm like,
aw man,
I want to be the one.
So if you have mark with you,
you're good.
You want your dessert,
that's what you want.
I don't want to say that,
but it looks so anyways.
If you get milk,
you can have dessert every night.
You can have dessert every day.
You can have breakfast,
Moelleken dinner
cause it's a,
it's a meal and actually life was asking me,
it's like,
what does [inaudible] mean?
Anyways,
I was like,
I made it up.
He's like,
what do you mean you paid off?
Because I had made it up.
How did you meet?
What was the making up process?
Have you ever tasted it and what did you think when you first tasted it?
Taste like a dessert to me.
I was like,
Oh man,
this is good mold and it just came out.
There's no other way to describe it.
It wasn't milking,
it wasn't ice cream,
it was something else.
There's something new,
so there you go.
Mauk it's a mint chocolate milk.
Probiotics in it is a big deal.
You were like,
Oh yeah,
I guess what I was probably biotics we've striked guests.
You is cool.
That's your whole that man.
That's a huge deal.
I know.
I know that now that now that I realize how it settles your stomach,
but you know what else?
Speaking of Dave Berg,
Dave,
you know how like I'm willing to mentor her milk.
Sorry.
Yes sir.
I do.
His flavor happens to be peanut butter chocolate,
like that's his deal.
So He's,
he's like a crack addict.
Like windows would say chocolate bean coming off.
So when he was just coming out,
um,
and then,
and then he said
it's not coming out for a long time.
And I was like,
yeah,
it's going to be like another three or four weeks or five weeks.
And he's like,
I know that's a mall,
so take it easy Dave.
We got you.
Gotcha.
Um,
be honest.
I agree with Dave.
I feel it's the exact same way.
And peanut butter chocolate happens to me.
My second favorite as well.
What's your first favorite mint chocolate chip.
You're fully in the game.
Hundred percent.
Actually.
They're even energy never made that connection.
Yeah,
I might've mentioned it.
Maybe they did it.
I remembered that.
So you're pumped.
You're all about that mall.
I know you're 100% on board.
I try not to admit too much of my liking for desserts around you.
A tame that back,
but the,
hey,
the facts are the facts.
Yeah,
the mock,
and actually I didn't mention this where it's like,
you know,
you do the one scoop or whatever.
I don't do the one scoop or I put it in the,
in the big 30 ounce due to three scoops.
Even little bit of Phil,
I don't know.
I fill it up.
Well,
you just said 30 ounce or you're talking to 30 ounces?
Yeah,
probably not to the top.
Top 20 2023 ounces.
Sure.
24 25 and you're putting two,
three scoops.
Three scoops in and scoops it thick.
Is that because I'm doing like 20 ounces of milk and two scoops?
It's not extra thick,
I think,
but that's just what my standard,
I don't know.
Like what's the style?
I don't really take protein powders or nothing like this,
so,
hey,
thick,
good.
Actually put an egg in there,
put it in the blender.
Dang right.
You really want to get nuts.
I'd do that for like the squat or the experience.
No.
All right,
so that's milk you want to go to on some,
get some origin main.com.
Yes.
Origin main.com is where you ordered and you can also get it on Amazon.
FYI,
if you didn't know that.
Hey,
speaking of origin main.com if you want to come to the Jujitsu immersion camp is
August 26 through September 2nd there's two.
What phases,
sessions,
or we can go to the whole thing.
Somebody asked if we're going to go to the origin factory.
If you want to come see the factory.
Yes,
we're going to be,
the factory visit isn't in the middle of the week and we'll be doing Jujitsu all
the time,
so get some,
we'll see their ongoing echo's going.
Echo is going to be incapacitated because I,
oh,
so you'd just be in a knowledge acquiring mode.
Yeah,
and and knowledge sharing mode isn't technically I,
I could,
I could rule,
but okay.
Then we roll with Brian.
Viglione comes in,
starts getting nuts.
I can't rule with him.
Well maybe it could.
No,
I shouldn't.
It'd be irresponsible for me to roll heart.
Put it that way.
He didn't care.
He came here and rolled it isn't,
he was jacked up.
Right.
He's neat.
Yeah.
But it's different.
Like a muscle tendon attachment is directly correlated.
Injury wise,
directly correlated with how hard you go on that muscle directly.
So you'll be a limited basis,
but you'll be there to share knowledge,
receive knowledge,
hang out,
kick it,
eat lobster.
Yes.
Oh Dang.
Echo is gonna be there.
I'm going to be there.
Dave Burke is going to be,
their life is going to be there.
Jp I believe is marginal right now.
We're not 100%,
but whatever.
We'll be there.
We'll be hanging out and uh,
like black belts Galore.
I forgot that part.
Yeah.
Black Belts Galore.
There'll be a bunch of black belts and then every other belt.
Yeah,
a huge deal.
Knowledge wise.
Even training wise.
Yeah.
Cause most everyone's going to be training.
So you get to experience like cause cause um,
yeah sometimes it's like if you,
some people have never rolled with it,
but some people never know.
Some people have never trained before and they're gonna come to the camp that
happened last year.
People have never trained before it came to the camp.
But I'm sorry I cut you off and you're going to say that some people never
rolled to the black belt before.
Like even if they had been training for even like a year or something like that.
Some,
you know,
sometimes that's how it goes,
you know?
Or if it's like,
hey,
I want to roll with Jocko specifically.
Are you kidding?
You're good.
I'm good.
Last year I had a rib issue this year.
No issues whatsoever.
No good.
So that's that.
Boom.
And also switching gears,
just another good way to support the podcast and oneself.
Jack the store,
it was called Jocko store website chocolate store.com I know.
Super simple but that's the way we keep it.
I keep it simple now too.
Yeah,
that's a law of combat actually.
Exactly right.
Boom.
And you practice what you preach.
As we all know,
anyone,
[inaudible] dot com this is where you can get chocolate here.
Like you can get rash guards and you used to always go on a big tangent about
how it's for all activities.
Sure it is.
Yeah,
I do when the water's warm,
but right,
right now by the way out here in California,
the water's warm.
You do not need a wet suit at this time to surf.
And so yeah,
the origin rash guards very effective for surfing the Jocko white rash guards.
Also very effective for surfing and cycling and cycling and whatever else.
Yeah.
And everything that's um,
yes,
again,
Jocko store.com is where you can get all this stuff.
T shirts,
the ones that say discipline equals freedom.
Get after it.
Tank tops by the way.
Oh yeah.
And I'll also on Amazon there's fake Jocko tee shirts.
Yeah.
I'm,
I'm cool.
I'm happy that you're in like trying to get in the game and that's cool.
It's a cool way to like feel cool about stuff and you can do that but you are
not supporting that is therefore it does not go to that support goes to someone
that a pirate.
A pirate.
Yeah,
but not like not a cool part or not a cool pie.
Just a thief.
So watch out for those.
If you get your tee shirts,
get them from Jocko store.com also,
you can get trucker hats.
Yes.
Which you seem to be really surprised at.
Trucker hats would look cool on me.
You told me you were like,
I need a picture of the situation.
I don't know that I can get right here.
Get the flak where they flex.
Flex fit.
See that?
That's what everyone's all pumped for.
I'm old school.
Yeah.
And then beanies to yes sir.
Which,
which beanies for me.
This is a,
so I sleep when I'm on planes.
Sure.
You went on a plane.
I sleep.
I put a beanie on my head.
Oh,
well sleep.
You sleep for like four minutes.
Yeah.
The legs.
Oh yeah,
that's right.
You've been on the plane with me.
Yes sir.
Have A,
so I'll put my head up against the bulkhead as they call it in a plane.
And the beanie keeps your head from a little tiny valuations going the whole
time.
You just need that little beanie.
It's like a pillow.
Yup.
So I put on a beanie and sleep.
If you see me,
don't bother me.
Um,
and then I'll wake up and four minutes later be ready to rock and roll and
right.
And another book.
Yes sir.
So when you say,
Oh,
I sleep on the plane,
who's think I sleep on the plane,
go use on the plane.
That's what I'm saying.
It's amazing.
Yes sir.
I was impressed by your sleeping capabilities that you,
you had sunglasses on.
Yes.
You were asleep for four straight hours.
You know,
you look like those.
What are those Chinese statues?
Um,
in the big vault where they have like thousands of Chinese soldiers all lined
up.
Yeah.
I don't know.
Anyways,
that's what I looked like.
You just look like a pro.
You did not move out and you did not move.
Your head stayed straight up and he just sat there asleep.
Just so disruptive to sleep.
I sleep on the plane.
I'm like,
you know,
it depends on what you mean by sleep,
but I get it.
And the beanies eliminate.
That makes sense.
Yeah.
They allow it and they keep the head warm.
Yeah,
it was going to say they do have other uses and even let's face it,
they look kind of cool.
Yeah,
for sure.
Well,
yeah,
I know you don't know about that either.
I don't know about sleeping or looking cool.
None the less they are available.
Bed is true.
Also women's stuff.
Okay.
Lot of times people will ask me,
hey,
make more a women's stuff.
Okay.
And I will,
but there's web stuff on their tanks and shirts and whatnot.
The rash guards are kind of for everybody as well.
But yeah.
Good stuff on that.
Good women's stuff.
Good stuff to get afterward in.
And hoodies.
Yes.
Don't forget about hoodies.
Yeah.
I want to make a new hoodie.
You might not approve of this,
I think.
Why are we making things that I don't approve of?
Do you know?
Sometimes they,
hey look,
I don't break the rules every,
why won't I approve of it?
Except sometimes because it's lightweight.
It's a lighter weight Hoodie.
Can we did it might be a zip up as the Hawaiian version.
Wait,
why would someone want to Hoodie?
That's not going to keep more.
It'll keep you a little bit warm cause sometimes it cause you're going to,
you can't,
you know when you're sleeping or when you're trying to go sleep at night,
right.
And then you put the covers on,
you're like,
Dang,
I'm too hot.
You take the covers off.
Oh it's like too cold.
So you got to get in that little zone that you can't get into sometimes.
Every once in a while it's like that.
So sometimes in life it's like that.
Okay,
while we're doing this,
can we make ultra,
I want the possible weight that they make it in America.
This is what we're going to do.
I'm going to get with Pete.
All right.
And we're going to figure it out.
Fabricate whatever even.
Yeah.
Even when you talked to Pete,
like let me get the samples.
I want them in my hands.
I want to feel the weight not playing around with this Hawaiian Love Hawaii.
As you know,
it's my homeland,
but I'm not down with the Hawaiians sweatshirts.
Hey,
so
where are you going to wear a heavy,
heavy hoody?
Not here.
You're talking to when you go to Montana or something like this?
Montana.
Michigan.
Yeah.
Boston.
It's cold in the morning here.
Okay.
How [inaudible] 33 degrees.
36 degrees.
38 degrees.
Go Surfing in the morning sometime.
We May,
I see what's up and I'm going to try wearing hoodies.
Surfery first.
No,
you wear it to go surfing.
Surfing.
Okay.
All right.
Hey,
I'm going to take your word for that and actually I have a heavy Hoodie I think.
Do you have a like a super ultra and I only wear it when it's unreasonably cold
in my opinion.
Quite much from years 62.
Yeah.
Know 50 either way.
Boom.
I told him to do the summer one.
You know what?
I think this is more what I predict.
I predict people will like tell him.
Yeah,
I think so very much actually.
Okay.
We'll see.
We'll check your fashion sense.
Um,
which I have none so we could go with it.
Also subscribe to the podcast,
iTunes,
Google play,
stitcher,
Spotify.
Someone just told me Spotify on your podcasts.
On Spotify.
We can fast forward without having a subscription or something like that.
So we're just on Spotify just full on whatever.
It's all good.
And also leave.
If you want to leave a review,
give us some feedback.
That's cool.
And you can do like one dude did who put an Oom lout over every oh,
in his reveal.
So obviously in the game he know photo cool.
Youtube too.
Yup.
Yeah.
The Youtube,
the thing about youtube is echo makes,
he's not going to say this because he's super humble,
right?
Nobody makes the,
the,
the enhanced videos,
which are legit and if you want to watch him,
you got to go there.
And He seems to be putting up more and more excerpts of little videos,
little clips of the podcast so you can share them sharable.
It wasn't there some like lunch thing called a shareable.
I think that was a lunchable.
Oh,
okay.
Yeah.
Sorry.
Yes,
man.
You kind of knew,
but the drinking too much job.
Oh yes.
Very sharp.
I tried to you,
uh,
choose or put up the ones that I think apply to all us in one way or another.
So many times like people will say,
Hey,
this is just on time right here,
this little message cause they were thinking this or something like that because
it applies to all of a sudden throw one of our bros.
That's kind of a,
you know,
we're not super tight,
but we're,
we're,
he came out to me,
he was like,
hey man,
he went through a little rough patch with a,
with a female.
Yes.
And he went through the whole breakup scenario and he was like,
I watched that video a hundred times.
The breakup one.
Yup.
Yeah,
yeah.
Like you said,
you happen to put that out there and he happened to somebody,
somebody,
one of our other friends sent it to him like,
hey,
check this out.
And he was like,
oh,
okay,
got it.
Now he's moving on as it should be and it's way simpler and more effective.
I mean in a scenario like that where rather than Sydney,
hey,
remember that episode with that in and it's like two,
two and a half hours long.
Hey,
read a watch.
I timestamp,
this is a good message to pie.
I'm not going to do all that,
you know,
but if it's just x or you just made it sound like it's all laziness,
not necessarily laziness.
Like there's sometimes there's some nuggets that just need to be put out there
to the world.
Yeah.
And it's not just because you didn't want it.
Some people don't have time to listen to it.
Just,
you know.
Yeah man.
Jocko.
Mcnuggets remember though,
I'm also good way to support is on it.com/jocko good fitness stuff on there.
I just got some,
um,
you know what?
You know what?
I got Elk Bacon,
elk,
you know,
like where are your bars?
They're warrior bars.
I think they're brand new.
Did you get those here?
So good.
You know what I have for you too is I have a mace for you.
I have a 20 pound mace that I've been hoarding at my house and I apologize,
but I owe it to you.
I'll bring it next time.
So cute cause they're there.
You know what I use those four people said,
what do you do with those?
Basically I swung them around like a maniac,
psycho barbarian with a battleax.
Yeah,
but they're a little shorter,
but they're heavy and I put it into my,
I'll put it into my
routine.
I want to say routine because that's every day I put it into a workout almost as
like a little mobility slash cardio slash something break.
It's,
it's a good tool to have.
It's a good tool to have.
I got to do you think the 20 pounder,
the 20 pounder looks light.
When I give it to,
you're gonna be like,
Oh,
I'm going to know it's,
it's heavy.
We'll consider a side from a 20 pound weight,
like what weighs 20 pounds?
Nothing.
Huge things.
TV or something like this.
And then you see amazing.
How,
how long is it not going?
As long as you're sure it's probably,
it might might not even be two feet long.
It's 20 pounds.
20 pounds.
Yeah.
So your,
your eyes and your brain and your body kind like Kinda miscalculating you know
by observation you pick it up and you're like,
Dang,
this thing is heavy.
Yeah.
So do it.
Actually that's perfect.
I go walk down this canyon right outside my house is,
and I always feel like I want to carry something you dose thing.
If you had it as a weapon it would not be effective.
It's too heavy.
Yeah.
It's like that.
That's how heavy it is.
It'd be cool to carry and I'm sure if you had a blood into someone to death with
it,
you could,
it would be not an ideal weapon against a mountain mine,
which is like the big threat here.
When you're walking to the canyon behind your house,
you know,
you get the mountain lion,
you're gonna re rear that Mesa got you by the neck.
Actually it's more just ticket.
Usually I'll grab like a thin stick,
just,
it's just,
it's just fun.
You know,
it'd be solid.
I'm looking forward to that one,
but hey,
that elk,
uh,
I don't even know if they call it a worry part,
but it's l bacon.
There's a 21 grams of protein in that 21 that's good.
And it's one of those things that can kind of keep you on the path.
If you're in the mood for a little song,
a hundred percent kind of like psychological warfare.
The album,
you get that on,
well you can get it on iTunes,
Google play and B three it's a little album talking about how to stay on the
path.
That's all.
Get some,
yeah.
Well actually in the spirit of meticulous accuracy,
it'll help you.
It's an album about telling you why and how you should stay on the path.
Yeah.
In those moments of weakness,
when you kind of feel,
actually it's not,
when you feel like getting off the path path,
it's when you don't feel like staying on that path for that moment.
This will get you right back.
Cool.
100% effectiveness Jocko Willink cause the artist.
Yes sir.
Yeah.
You can get it on Amazon,
iTunes,
wherever we get MPPS.
That's where you get it.
Also Jocko white tea,
try t and in a can by the way.
So the dry tea,
he was thinking,
I didn't know this,
so I'm gonna say it by,
and I know a lot of people would be like Kung Fu.
Oh all the dog already knew that.
I remember like we were saying earlier,
but dry tea,
dry tea is like the actual one.
You got to brew this tea bags then?
Yes.
Yeah.
Like in a bag or whatever.
He comes in a tea bag.
Wait,
can't you have it?
Like what do you call it?
Loose loose leaf.
And we do not have loose links.
That's not dry.
You know,
for the seven people out there that want loose leaf passionately,
I feel you.
And I just had a woman the other day that was like,
Hey,
I really want loose leaf tea.
And I was like,
oh,
that's awesome.
And there's six other of you that want that.
And as we grow,
eventually we'll do loose leaf for the purists.
Right.
For the PRS that want to deal with that.
Yeah.
That have the time to deal with that.
So right now,
no loose leaf.
You got to go with a tea bag or in a can get,
which strangely I'm the opposite.
I don't know if I'd be considered opposite of the loose leaf artisans,
but they can,
I pound way more of the camp then the pin,
cause I don't like brew it,
but they can't.
Oh,
I'm popping them everyday surprisingly too,
because I don't see how there's tea drinkers technically,
whatever.
I'm not a tea drinker.
This is what I think is going to be interesting.
It tastes really good.
Yes.
It makes you feel really good.
It's refreshing.
Right?
He's just there that got that thing that dislike is good.
Right.
Okay.
I,
I think one of the standard energy drinks,
they're filled with sugar and they,
and they,
they,
they got everything in there to make them taste good.
That's what they're set up for and they got the caffeine that's going to make
you feel good and all this stuff.
As good as those things are the,
the dark away t it's better.
It's,
it's,
it's like if you had the choice of one of the two,
like let's,
okay,
let's be real.
I'm going to be real here with you right now for a second.
If I had the choice between like a salad and a mint chocolate chip ice cream
milkshake,
if I had to spill my heart spill y'all to you right now,
I'd be like if you put those two in front of me,
nine times out of 10 I'm going to get the mint chocolate chip milkshake.
Occasionally I'll be like,
okay,
I'll have a salad cause I'm really in the mood for that,
but nine times out of 10 like I'm just going to go with what you know,
which is that majority geography of milkshake is good with this.
Nine Times out of the 10 you're actually going to get Jocko white tea.
You're not going to take the thing.
You're not going to get the thing that's been engineered to be like attack your
taste buds and make them massage and feel good and you don't know.
You don't want to feed.
This is obviously an assumption,
but when you get like,
okay,
you have a duck white tea in a k,
then you have a standard energy drink,
the standard energy drink.
I think the taste is more of a secondary thing.
When they make it,
it's more like,
you know,
get you and like the caffeine and the the whatever.
But they make that stuff tastes good.
Yes,
but that's secondary.
That's why like birth tastes to energy drink.
It's like okay,
you know all the tastes okay,
it tastes good,
but it's like it can be an acquired taste.
It tastes kind of weird to be honest with you and that's a good point with this,
it's like how you say,
I don't want to overuse the word refreshing.
Don't want to do that.
Well,
what was just going to say is in order to not overuse that word,
have you ever,
okay,
remember when you were a kid and you doing something,
you're all hot and sweaty,
tired,
like it's hot outside and you're thirsty.
And so you're,
you get a Gatorade and you drink the Gatorade and when you get down the Gatorade
you're still thirsty because it's got whatever it hasn't it that doesn't taste
like water.
It's like too far away from water.
When you,
when you drink the tea,
it's like an actual,
it actually satisfies the actual thirst.
Yes it does.
Yeah.
Cause it's,
it's super mild.
It is mine.
It is mild.
But it does have a weird kind of,
I mean,
I don't want to overstate this,
but it's like this crispy kind of feeling.
It could be the kid,
it could be
the cat.
I don't,
you know how you drink some man,
I get this same thing.
So how's this?
So two occasions is legitimate and recent.
That's why.
So to eight and one time I was feeling kind of sick.
I was sick.
Oh.
Straight up,
sick.
And I was feeling like,
aw,
you know,
I took,
I was sick to the point where I got to take like one of these,
you know,
a lot of no Nyquil,
the Nyquil,
it was like Tylenol,
you know,
the liquid one,
the little,
the red syrupy liquid one.
And it's been so long since I took anything like that.
So I was like,
I don't know how much you take,
let me,
so I put it in little shot glass that I had and I just pounded it.
Apparently it was too much.
So I'm like,
oh,
I'm like jammed up.
Super jammed up,
like super nauseous,
had all messed up.
Like,
oh,
I couldn't really think tech that was messed up and we had to record that day.
So this was earlier,
like in the morning and this how I'm like,
shoot,
I'm hoping I'm off this thing.
I just kind of laid out and whatever.
And I brought,
it wasn't off it.
When I came in and recorded,
I was like,
man,
I'm like super nauseous.
I'm not feeling good.
So I tried to drink like some,
uh,
caffeine thing to kind of probably didn't help.
It was messing me up.
So I grabbed one of these and instantly now not that came like I drink something
and then I ended up feeling better.
It was like I drink and I was like,
Dang,
instantly felt better.
So I was like,
you know,
could have been a timing thing.
Whatever,
100% full credit cards,
it's 100% but the thing is that's a
total anecdotal,
I realize,
but,
and then another time I drank,
I,
okay.
So I'm unlike you,
like I do like coffee,
you know,
for the,
the caffeine,
right in the morning,
whenever.
So I come across this coffee,
the brand,
we will remain nameless,
but it's 1.75 times,
almost two times the caffeine,
200% it's 175% Catholic of the caffeine.
That's a lot of caffeine.
So I'm like,
Hey,
I'm gonna get this.
And you know,
if it's like too crazy,
I'll just make less of it or drink glass of water down,
whatever.
So I make something first time,
it totally messes you up.
It puts you,
caffeine is like a curve where you want to hit it at the top of the wave.
You know where it catches you.
If you drink too much.
It makes me feel jittery and then if you just really drink too much,
it makes me feel kind of sick.
In my experience.
This just regular,
the same amount I drink of regular coffee,
it put me over into nausea immediately.
No,
like belly dude.
it wasn't like pain,
like how something it'll,
it's like it's in your head,
it makes your head all Weigley at whatever.
And so I'm like,
man,
I'm messed up for this thing.
So the next day I'm like,
I'm not going to drink tasks.
Like no,
you know what,
I'll water it down.
So I watered down,
boom,
same exact thing.
Messed me up and happened to be yet another day that we record.
So I come in,
I'm like all came to and it grab another one of these seeds again instantly.
Immediately.
It didn't like,
oh help it wear off later or whatever.
Like immediately made me feel better.
No nausea.
I'm not saying this is an antinausea medication,
but I will tell you this,
you're just providing multiple examples.
I will say that about the Jocko white tea in a cat organic certified.
Yes sir.
Alright,
cool.
Uh,
got some books
that I've written and you can get those on.
Boy.
You can get them where books are sold.
Yeah.
This what is not the best one.
The current one that I'm on right now,
me and my daughter,
we have the word kid to mark the mission.
Actually.
She was very,
very excited about that,
I think.
Cause you signed it too,
but yeah.
But yeah,
that's a good one.
Um,
and she happened to be,
you know,
in the beginning the paper Miss Shea.
Oh yeah.
Pumpkin.
Yeah.
She was really into that by the way.
But she has a situation where one of the girls in her class classes,
like she's not a teaser necessarily,
but she's just bossy and now you've got to deep just got to deal with people.
I get a lot of warrior kid podcast questions about bossy kids.
Yeah.
And it's,
yeah,
me and it makes sense.
But she has,
she's,
she's all on that.
And so that's another thing worth mentioning is there's the warrior kid books,
two of them where the warrior kid and Mark's mission and there's also a warrior
kid podcast called warrior kid podcast.
Yeah.
And ask Uncle Jake,
so you can check that one out.
There's also the discipline equals freedom field manual,
which tells you how to get after it
very clearly.
And if you want to get it on audio,
the only way you can get it on your audio is as an it MP3 album.
Or you can buy individual tracks if you want them,
iTunes,
Amazon music,
Google play,
et cetera.
Yeah.
Also extreme ownership.
Yes.
The do you don't feel there are regional right ownership?
No,
this is the second version now.
It's like an enhanced version goes clips.
There's sections from the Po,
from this podcast in the new extreme ownership.
Yeah.
That's the,
when they come out,
when they release a book,
they want to add a little spice to it.
Make sense?
So the spices,
the podcast actually,
which is pretty cool.
So extreme ownership book sprinkled with podcasts.
Yeah.
Spice Spicy podcasts.
Yes.
Yeah.
Um,
good ones.
Simple but not easy balance.
But if you can assimilate it legitimately life changing.
What's,
what's cool to me.
Yeah.
You know,
you just threw out life changing.
You just threw it out there.
No big deal.
I'm not the only one.
No,
that's what I'm saying.
What's cool,
what's cool is when people are pretty stoked about the impact that it's had on
their personal life and on their business and on their family.
And I hear people talking about that and they,
they come and talk to me about it and send me emails and everything else.
It's awesome.
So that's the book.
Extreme ownership.
Wrote it with my brother Leif Babin and Lafe and I just wrote another book.
I kind of referenced it a couple times day.
It's called the dichotomy of leadership and the wife and I literally,
I keep saying,
we just get done writing it.
Have you heard me say that on this podcast before,
while I have,
you know why?
Because every time you edit,
you edit again.
So every time you think you're done,
you're not done.
And so we just turned in another series of edits and the edits are,
it's not like we're going through these massive changes,
but you just,
you just,
somebody changes something in a sentence and then it throws off this other
thing.
And so just to,
um,
the way though,
that's what we're doing.
Do you have the philosophy like I'm on a,
I forget who said it,
but it's like editing gets done when you can take away no more.
No,
it's the opposite.
Yes.
Editing is done when you can't,
you can't.
Every word matters and that's what you want.
And you know,
Lafe and I Lafe Lafe basically like,
I do like a thousand words a day and I edit the same way.
Well,
I edit,
you can edit faster.
So I'll edit like one chapter at a time,
but then I'll do that one per day.
Laughs the opposite.
He just goes boom.
He just goes and he'll call me at like midnight broad
open ended for each dollars and they go to chapter nine.
I'm like,
that's awesome man.
But yes.
And then we edit each other.
And so we're,
it takes a while.
So we just finished another series of edits and both of us are stuck.
Lafe sent me a text the other day,
he's like,
Bro,
this book,
this book is awesome.
It is actually.
Oh that's right.
Cause you don't have,
we'll taste it.
It now
it is,
I think it's really gonna help people out.
And again,
you can preorder that thing right now so that the publisher Prince enough so
that people can actually have them.
Cause the publishers don't ever get it.
And it doesn't mean it does help in,
I'm ready.
I don't want to,
I want to give it away any kind of swell or nothing like that.
But it does,
it makes complete sense,
especially after extreme ownership where extreme ownership like eh,
and it kind of has this tone of extremeness,
which is,
it's all true and accurate,
but I can see how like someone,
someone might not get that little element of like,
hey,
it's extreme,
but it's more of like this approach to like this horse and that whole thing is
this balance.
Yes.
I actually wrote in the book dichotomy.
Leadership.
Yeah.
One of the PR,
one of the problems with extreme ownership as the title extreme ownership
because people think it got to be extremely,
no,
actually you need to,
you need to not be extreme.
Most of the time as a leader,
you need to be balanced.
Now do you need to be extreme and your attitude towards ownership?
Yes,
you absolutely do.
But do you need to be extreme and your attitude of being aggressive?
No,
because if you get too aggressive,
you're going to cause other problems.
Yeah.
Like extreme meaning like don't deviate from thinking like this kind of thing.
Not like when I go in,
I'm just owning everything.
No exceptions.
What you say doesn't matter.
This is mine.
Kind of kind of extreme.
It's not that.
And then really the extremeness of the balance.
It's almost like a contradictory thing,
but it's all the parts that like I'm using it for a little something that have
to,
that I'm,
I have to do it,
but you know,
anyway,
I'm reading some of it.
Yeah.
And it's like,
man,
it makes it really clear.
It's really good.
Yeah,
no,
that's,
that's what life texted me the other day.
I'm like,
yeah,
cause obviously we've been reading a bunch and I think it's going to really help
people out really help people out the green.
So that'll be good.
And you know,
actually on top of the dichotomy of leadership,
because speaking of leadership,
if you need leadership training on site for you or your team,
you can check out echelon front.
That's my leadership consulting company with life,
with JP,
with Dave.
We've got some other people coming on board right now,
which is awesome.
Awesome guys.
And what we do is we solve problems through leadership.
That's what we do at echelon front.
Ashkelon front.com come and get some.
Yup.
Effectively I feel like I'm kind of like this ongoing client of echelon front
of,
you know,
of your consulting,
just cause I'm always kind of around.
Yeah.
It's interesting how just by,
what do you call it?
Osmosis known is osmosis.
Just by being there,
it kind of said to your brain,
it's good.
Also the muster,
that's a big part.
Look,
I'm essentially an attendee at the muster with a camera with a camera,
which is even more so because I get to rewatch it.
Certain parts.
Oh yeah.
You get to get up,
move around,
get close.
Outstanding time,
by the way.
And so yeah,
there's a net,
there's another one,
the the one,
the last one we went to sold out before that one sold out.
DC was pretty awesome.
Yeah.
I mean,
and it was a base,
well,
let me,
DC was awesome.
It was just awesome being in DC and the master was a good time and people
learned a ton.
So yeah.
Sold out again.
All of them.
Yeah.
And
so it's reasonable,
as you always say,
to belief that this next one is going to sell out.
Oh,
the next one is going to sell out.
Yeah.
They're definitely gonna sell out.
It's a San Francisco Monster,
zero zero six October 17th and 18th it's absolutely going to sell out.
So if you want to come register,
the other thing that happens is if you book hotel rooms,
you know,
because those things get bought,
bought up too.
So,
yeah,
it's,
it's a leadership seminar.
We talk about leadership and it's not just talking about leadership,
we actually give you the pragmatic tools that you need to take home and become a
better leader in your business,
in your life.
I was watching this,
I was watching TV the other day because my kids were watching TV.
It wasn't my choice by the way.
That's nonetheless I'm watching TV and I see a little,
you know,
the commercial,
it's almost,
it's the local like commerce,
you know how the commercial one commercial kind of starts and then it goes to
the local commercial,
you know,
that situation.
And that happens.
So anyway,
it's for this seminar,
you know,
for,
I don't,
I forget where,
maybe real estate or whatever,
you know,
cool,
cool info or whatever.
And you know how in the video they show a,
you know like clips from the actual seminar that they held last time or
something like that,
Bro,
I'm going to,
and then you can't help but compare it to
like the muster situation and it's like men night and day,
you know you,
I'm the as cool looks like people are getting good information put pro.
It's just way different than this.
That's why,
that's why they're all selling out.
That's why people are people coming back.
So there's that added element where they kind of get to hang with you guys.
Oh yeah.
Yeah that's true.
There's no green room.
There's no behind the scenes.
You're actually the last one,
there was literally no backstage,
there was no place.
We were just out front.
We were out front of the whole time.
The whole team.
Not that you would even need it because you kind of,
you don't go back there.
No,
you can't Kinda can't.
No Green Room.
Even when you say there's a break,
there's already a line kind of formula.
Okay.
Cause you know,
you get questions,
but I want to ask questions in between and sign books and hang out and take
pictures and all that stuff.
That's what we do the whole time.
Yeah.
No,
forgot to mention we're all the same hotel.
Lafe Lafe lost nine pounds during the muster two,
seven.
Really.
Cause that's what we're doing.
We're just and going no time to eat.
Like,
like we literally don't eat.
You don't eat cause you,
I mean we don't,
you can eat as um,
as a attendee.
You can eat but like leave me,
the boys wouldn't have time to eat.
We're working.
And so yeah,
coming to muster also,
uh,
for current military law enforcement,
border patrol,
firefighters,
paramedics,
first responders,
we got the roll call September 21st in Dallas,
Texas.
It's a
like a really focused one day leadership training seminar aimed at people that
put on a uniform and deal with dynamic situations.
And that's also available to register@extremeownership.com and until we see you
live and in person,
either at the muster in San Francisco or the roll call in Texas or the immersion
camp up in Maine,
if you want to,
if you want to hang out with us virtually,
we are hanging out actually on the inner webs.
Echo is at echocharles and I am at Jocko Willink and to all the service men and
women out there in the world.
Thank you for protecting our nation and to the police,
law enforcement,
firefighters,
paramedics,
border patrol.
Thanks for keeping us safe here at home and to the families of all those that
serve.
Thank you for supporting those heroes that support us
and to everyone else that is listening.
Remember as we learned today,
laziness is the shame of us all.
Laziness makes us prefer the easy path,
the week path
instead of glory.
Do not allow that.
Instead,
take the hard path,
take the discipline path,
take the war path,
the path of getting after it,
and until next time,
this is echo and Jocko.